we have a major story tonight this may
have some signif historical significance
the Georgia D.A published the
indictments against Donald Trump while
the grand jury is still in session they
have not convened yet they have not come
to determination yet somehow Reuters got
a hold of the charges already
the Assumption here is the D.A in
Georgia obviously anti-trump already
knows what they're charging him with and
the grand jury for show
it's a trick now many are calling for
Trump to file a lawsuit motion to
dismiss on constitutional grounds that
this is well it's tainted
I mean this is shocking earlier today I
tweeted out the story from Reuters
breaking news they're set to charge
Trump the documents have been released
and then shortly after they removed
those documents and said whoops
but they're already planning on
indicting it we'll talk about that we
got a couple other stories Joe Biden
when asked while he's vacationing mind
you during one of the greatest
ecological disasters in this country's
history the wildfires in Maui the worst
fires in 100 years he's asked what do
you have to say he says no comment
he is completely abandoned the people of
adult but don't don't worry he'll go to
Ukraine he'll send them all your money
so we'll talk about that plus uh and we
got some cellular news too I guess Elon
Musk apparently shows did he show up to
Zuckerberg's house or knock knock he
said he's going to show up to
Zuckerberg's house he wants to fight
all right we'll talk about that before
we get started my friends support the
show over at castbrew.com by buying our
coffee we sponsor ourselves we have a
bunch of different sponsors most
podcasts have sponsors cast brew coffee
is our coffee company we've got ground
and whole bean light dark light dark and
medium roasts we have decaf we also have
K-Cups and if you would like to honor
the memory of Roberto Jr who died
suddenly last week of we believe it was
heart failure then you can purchase rise
with Roberto Jr and check out the
commercial for casparu which has got
three so I think it's like a 3.5 million
views already if you if you go to
twitter.com timcast I have it pinned to
the top of my page you can watch the
commercial we had a lot of fun making
that we'll be rolling that out soon so
again casper.com buy our coffee support
the show or head over to timcast.com and
click join us to become a member and
support us directly and you'll get
access to our exclusive members only
uncensored show coming up at about 10
a.m tonight and if you've been a member
for at least six months or you sign up
at 25 per month level you can submit
questions and even call into the show to
talk to us and our guest so do that and
uh joining us so smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more is
Joel W Gibbons
how are y'all doing who are you so I'm
Joel Gibbons I'm the host of Man vs
Street on YouTube uh brought to you by
The Daily Caller and I interview people
about cultural and political events
happening in the world and a little
couple jokes here and there too right on
well thanks for hanging out this should
be a lot of fun we also have Hannah
Claire hanging out hey I'm Hannah
clarema writer for timcast.com I'm happy
I'm here I've been here too yeah I am
thank you Hannah Claire Ian cross on it
what's up everybody happy Monday night
middle of August coming at you now Serge
what's happening Brother Hey I'm
search.com pleasure to see you guys and
uh let's just get on the show this is
this is a huge story I think when they
look back on this period this will be a
key component of it from Politico
Georgia Court posts then removes
document detailing charges against Trump
the document which which Reuters first
reported came from the Fulton County
Court listed 12 felony counts and one
serious felony count for violating
George's RICO Act
here's the thing the grand jury
is is still in they have been convened
how could they have these documents
ready to go many
they're suggesting that the Georgia D.A
planned to charge Trump regardless of
what the grand jury actually did
Politico says the county court in
Georgia where Donald Trump is expected
to be charged this week briefly posted
and quickly removed a document on Monday
detailing several charges against the
former president over his alleged
election interference in the state in
2020. the document which Reuters first
reported came from the Fulton County
Court includes Trump's name and lists
the cases status is open it is dated
August 14th and time stamps 12 39 PM the
document lists 12 felony accounts and a
serious felony count for violating their
RICO Act this is crazy I think we have
the document right here
this is it case information state of
state of Georgia versus Donald John
Trump you've got the case number the
filing date
I'm just going to say this right now
if there is a filing date on a court
document listing charges I can say
definitively they filed charges against
Trump now I think we can get semantics
semantic or orbit pedantic and say
perhaps filing a charging document is
different from literally bringing
charges against Trump but I think the
fact that they did this is telling and
no one is going to trust them over this
they've pulled this document down
they're issuing no comment so
I don't I don't know what to think about
this but it certainly seems I don't know
man
I I'm calling it seditious conspiracy
that they're they were working to take
down Trump the grand jury which is
supposed to be the normal process to
bring about indictments is meaningless
fake and they were going to do this
anyway because their real goal is to
cheat in the 2024 election so just as
the common man here I'm a little I just
don't know the process very well but a
grand jury is going to get together and
they're going to talk about what to
bring What charges to bring and then
after they decide they'll build a paper
like what we have here this case
information document but you're saying
that the grand jury hadn't even decided
yet and the document was already
prepared the grand jury just finished
hearing some testimony today they were
they're still in hearing evidence so
look again I'm not a lawyer
um but what I'm seeing from a lot of
high profile personalities and people
who are literally lawyers is that it it
appears that they've filed charges
against Trump with the grand jury still
in session well the thing that's crazy
to me about it is even if you're gonna
like indict Trump ultimately if you're
gonna do what you're doing this is a
vicious thing you're trying to over do
this election interference as of this
what this is what would it be why would
you release this document and then pull
it back like why would you already mess
up like your everybody doesn't believe
you even more now when you come out and
you do these things and now you're gonna
like put out like some kind of mass mess
up like this it could be that they just
want to be like look how much control we
have like they're just dangling it
they're like you can't stop us you think
they're just being arrogant I don't
think they are but that would be one
possibility that they're like yo we're
just gonna commit crimes in plain sight
now and you can't stop us I worked in
politics I don't think they're that
smart to be quite honest with you that's
like they get if they had this plan and
actually they will they could have been
they could have had this whole plan to
you know completely destroy Trump
already but and they messed up that's
another thing that politicians do all
the time they mess up consistently like
we see Bond do it pretty much every day
but like I just don't understand why
they would already release this and then
pull it back like I mean well they
screwed up obviously it can't it can't
be out there what I wonder is what
Trump's legal team is going to do in
response right because to be to to
basically imply no matter what he is
getting charged uh really raises
questions about due process he's not
even being indicted by a grand jury he's
being indicted by the lead prosecutor in
in Georgia which is crazy Mike cernovich
said Fulton County D.A indicted Trump
under George's RICO law Reuters obtained
the documents the grand jury is still
meeting the law isn't being followed
this is state-sponsored lynching Mike's
a lawyer
I mean so I can only imagine he
recognizes these documents but perhaps
there is some kind of uh argument I'm
trying to I'm trying to you know be
reasonable here maybe this is a list of
potential charges that are being
considered
I don't know but I I don't I don't know
how they pop like it seems at the if I
was gonna be nice to these people which
I I absolutely would never be they have
a list of potential charges that they
said whoops over and published yeah like
it's like this is what we want to charge
him with let's hope the grand jury goes
for it so we'll have the document ready
to go as soon as they say yes then we'll
publish it well either way they they
probably like how we do these things
well how I used to do this and we'd
write two things and be like this is
what is probably going to happen and one
of these two things might happen either
way they click that button first like
that was the first one they clicked so
there no matter what they say there's
going to be a little Edge to like they
think this indictment's coming in the
way they think it's going to come but
then Reuters blamed uh the Georgia court
system they said oh the court this
document was up and then they took it
down and because this link you can see
in the URL is a is a Reuters Foundation
link so they're saying it's not that we
messed up as reporters it's at the court
are we not talking I thought we were
talking about the court system like
trying to subvert him not the not
Reuters correct that's what I think yeah
I mean I think both right like if
Reuters who released who published the
story first is saying the the court
system had it up and then took it down
that's interesting because then Reuters
knew to look for the document which why
would it be out if the jury hasn't
convened that's a really good point how
did Reuters get tipped off the document
was published unless it's possible that
because the grand jury is in they have a
reporter reporter just sitting there
hitting refresh non-stop on this court
listing page it's totally reasonable
well they probably well they got a tip
well no uh Reuters actually I could be
totally wrong about this it's been a
very very long time since I had anything
ever to do with Reuters this is like 10
years ago when I knew a guy who worked
there my understanding is they they
actually archive and sell legal
documents oh really yeah so I mean this
might be right up their alley to say hey
look this document just dropped and then
GA was like how did this get published
whoops immediately took it down here's
what I gotta say if this document was
just a legitimate document pertaining to
the potential charges Trump is facing
they'd leave it up yeah there's nothing
to be afraid of and they would just say
this is the list of charges that the
grand jury is currently deliberating on
I think I I look man I'm not giving
these people the benefit of the doubt to
you if I was gonna if you were to ask me
what what is the reasonable solution the
simple system Occam's razor uh they
pre-planned charging Trump a long time
ago and the grand jury doesn't matter
and Georgia I feel like just has it out
for Trump George's I feel like then the
thorn in his side for so long so I'm not
really that's the other chart the other
cases seem a little bit uh more shallow
too this seems to be the big one I think
this is the one that people are really
worried about I think this is the case
that could really like destroy it well
the fabric of the government as we kind
of know it but
why do you think that it's just like
this is the one that could put Trump in
actual jail right that's what that's
what people have been telling me at
least but maybe what do you think it's
not so much that this is the one that
can put them in jail it's that this is
the one where there are zealous cult
members who want to put him in jail
regardless DC is scared to remind Trump
New York is scared to remain Trump the
sheriff in Georgia already said he's
getting that mug shot there they look
man this is amazing Republicans they're
conservative District Attorneys all over
the country they do nothing and now
you've got this novel reading of the law
coming out of Georgia where they say we
are going to indict the former president
and the current front-runner for the
Republican party and Republicans are
going oh gee golly yeah and it's doing
nothing and I think Georgia wants this
more than or else they're one of the
Swing States so Democrats in Georgia
want Trump to be indicted there and
solidly locked down as a blue State for
2024. the other thing that's interesting
about this and we were looking at the
indictments this is the fourth one right
this is number four I think every time
it's it's the it's the fourth
jurisdiction to issue indictments I
think it's like the 78th or something
okay okay so I think every time they've
done this issuance like over the I think
they like he's every time he's
fundraised he's just lost money each
time so I'm wondering how much money he
gets off of this one and if like that
really is like showing that his
support's gonna go down well it's an
issue of how much money do people have
so it's not that people aren't
supporting him anymore it's that a guy
who gets a hundred bucks a week in extra
cash already gave it to Trump can't give
it again yeah I think everyone has a
limit in terms of what they can give in
a political cycle especially you know a
year and a half out from the election or
less than a year and a half at this I
mean I think it's pretty obvious what
they're doing they are they're one
trying to remove Trump's name from the
ballot trying to put him in jail to stop
him from running and saddling him with
so much legal debt and uh paperwork that
he's unable to run anyway this is
cheating in an election period no
question you can remember this I hope in
a hundred years if they stumble upon
this podcast we said it they're cheating
they are targeting the front runner for
the Republican Party party that with the
most support who's set to win the
primary in in all of these ridiculous
ways with charges that are clearly bunk
and they're trying to reframe and
rewrite history to justify it yeah I
mean Trump's gonna have to campaign
completely around when he has court
appearances right all of 2024 which is
crazy to me on the other hand he has
such strong support from his base that
like if anyone could it's trump it seems
crazy that they're going to these
lengths to sort of slow him down uh but
today it seems farther than that it's
not just like meddling and trying to
make it hard for him it's they've
actually decided that he is going to get
indicted no matter what and that that
should make all of the voters you know
of both parties in Georgia angry
what do you guys think of this idea so
we threw this around the other day at my
office uh Biden uh complete like washes
Trump like what's it called
um he pardons Trump but Trump loses all
that momentum he gets from the
indictments all of a sudden the sanus is
back in the game what do you guys think
about that like if Biden decided that
you know but then he might be facing to
Santa so it's a terrible move on his
part but like like a curveball throwing
in there like what if he came out of
nowhere decided to Pardon Trump and all
of a sudden Trump's dead in the water at
that point I feel like I saw a video of
the Santa serving eggs to people and not
making eye contact with anybody like he
just looked like he was ashamed and
people like I'm just here for the eggs
one guy and people do that guy's he
already lost the race in my opinion I
don't think he has any chance how does
the campaign doing that like you're
gonna go have him serve eggs after he's
getting dogged all over the place like
uh it doesn't make him look like a cool
guy I know he should have been out
touring like Rama Swami is doing like
he's doing the basement Camp I mean it
seems like he's doing a basement
campaign I I haven't heard from him or
something I want to read this statement
here this is from Trump's lawyers
this was not a simple administrative
mistake Trump's attorneys Drew findling
and Jennifer little said in a statement
a proposed indictment should only be in
the hands of the District Attorney's
office yet it somehow made its way to
the clerk's office and was assigned a
case number and a judge before the grand
jury even deliberated okay that's false
then this is seditious conspiracy
against the United States happening in
your face in real time so do you file a
lawsuit now against the district
attorney file a lawsuit I know who do
you who files it
okay also what court is going to give
Trump a fair trial in this country
that's the real question right he can be
indicted in any state obviously Georgia
has already made a decision about how
they feel about him like that's the
problem he has a judge already that's
why you have a federal government so
when States go Rogue like this you can
take care of them unless it's a mafia
cult and they're working for the big guy
and they're doing exactly what he wants
Joe Biden's federal government yeah Joe
Biden's federal government that's
already got multiple indictments against
Joe Biden's Chief political opponent who
is polling above him I mean to your
point no I don't think Biden would ever
uh pardon Trump because I don't think
his base would be okay with that at all
I mean he is the their incumbent
candidate so he's their front runner in
a sense but he's not popular and he's
old and nobody really wants him there so
if he doesn't have enough uh Grace
within the party to Pardon Trump and
come off looking like oh you're standing
up for justice because a lot of his
supporters believe no matter what Trump
should go for go to jail they can't even
really name What charges they think he
should be convicted on that's why there
are so many you know it's like throwing
pasta at all and seeing what will stick
there's whatever whatever works they'll
agree there's not a single Conservative
Republican libertarian or otherwise
prosecutor in Georgia who is going to go
after what what this is I mean this is
at the bare minimum probable cause for a
conspiracy investigation yeah
and aren't they charging for some Rico
stuff too anyway so it's like a
conspiracy with a conspiracy like
they're doubling up
also like isn't Kemp the Republican
Governor gonna say something I mean I
don't even know what to say if he has he
been charged or not because they thought
they listed the charge like but he's not
the grand jury hasn't convened yet so or
hasn't decided on charges yet so what's
the process here do we who do you
we're supposed to be the greatest
country on earth like we're supposed to
have the best legal system and this is
the best like this is what we're dealing
with right now like the middle of an
election cycle like but I think that's
why we have to say like Georgia is a
swing state this is a political move on
behalf of all Democrats in Georgia right
if they can be the ones to get charges
to stick against Trump to actually
convict Trump first they would love that
that would lock down Georgia as a blue
state in 2024 I mean this is strategic
and they're going to you know disrespect
Justice to achieve their political means
it feels like it's a it's super bowl or
like a football game right they're just
want to see their team win the crazy
thing is that apparently the DA's office
The Fulton County Court Clerk's Office
referred to a quote fictitious document
that has been circulated online
as if to argue
the document isn't actually from them
and it's being shared randomly yet
Reuters has Georgia Court website
briefly publishes removes document about
about potential Trump charges it's a
pretty serious allegation from them if
they're saying Reuters fabricated a
document and that's what's being
circulated online wow that's a bold
claim right that's their defense well
here's the story either
there's a seditious conspiracy against
Donald Trump using the court system or
Reuters fabricated the news to smear
opponents of Donald Trump and Reuters is
a wire service so like it's where's a
lot of news originates everywhere if
they're the ones fabricating the news
that would be deeply concerning so
should Reuters file a lawsuit against
the person who's claiming that they are
are you defamation I mean maybe yeah
it's a lawsuit after a lawsuit it's like
lawsuits just for media because these
lawsuits don't get resolved for years so
like we're just sitting here so we can
freak out about it while they just keep
doing the same stuff it's insane like
and if you look at like what we're going
to impeach by now what's going to happen
then is that process going to go through
that's another what that's kind of a
lawsuit I guess not the same thing all I
want to talk about is graphene and I'm
talking about all I want to talk about
is fuel oh I want to talk about energy
costs because if we want to circumvent a
revolution of violent or revolution we
need to make energy cheaper we need to
make feel cheaper I know politics I mean
I should talk about the only reason from
it's it's one of the strongest reasons
for Revolution and civil unrest lack of
access to Food Water Shelter Etc
but it's not the only reason I'm in
political instability of course even
when there is food available but it does
tend to be food and and uh of course
energy I want to point this out too
because we have this from Atlanta news
first that's interesting August 10th
this is being highlighted in much of
these stories we have an announcement
Fulton D.A Willis launches fundraising
website
yeah oh the D.A launched a fundraising
website to make money at the same time
these indictments are pre-published we
should check that we should check the
receipts on that I don't know when that
comes out but I'm sure there's going to
be a pretty penny in there I was trying
to track down this is she running for
re-election I was trying to track this
down but I think she's a quote where
she's like yes we've we've really
accomplished what we meant to or
something like she uses the word
accomplished I'm gonna be like what do
you mean you had a goal and you achieved
it that doesn't sound right I wanna I
wanna uh pull up this story here from
CNN let's talk about this exclusive
Georgia prosecutors have messages
showing Trump's team is behind voting
system breach
are you guys familiar with the story at
all no no what do you think that
headline means Ian what does that
headline mean tell me what you think
Trump did
behind voting system breach it sounds
like they went into voting machines and
either stole code or observed something
they shouldn't have observed so so
messages showing Trump's team is behind
a voting system breach you're saying it
sounds like Trump's team broke into the
voting systems and stole codes you want
to know what the real story is yeah I
would love to account an election
official in Coffee County invited
Trump's legal teams his lawyers he'd
hired to come and inspect voting
machines
and the messages they have are Trump's
lawyers saying we've been invited down
to Coffee County by one of the election
officials to to take a look at the
machines so and CNN titled it that way
yeah the word breach then is a misnomer
could even be defamatory it sounds like
they uh maybe a voting system
observation but that wouldn't get clicks
so what's happened now is
people in the state are arguing that the
election official did not have the
authority to allow Trump's lawyers to
come and inspect the the machines
therefore it was an illegal breach of
their voting systems and that Trump's
team was behind it so I saw this it was
actually Brian krasenstino who tweeted
it and he said you know here's the story
from CNN Trump's team was behind it and
I was like wow I gotta know what this is
but I tell you what every time I hear a
psychotic story about Trump being some
criminal mastermind you read a couple
paragraphs and you realize it's all fake
news and what did I find you know what
CNN the best thing CNN could do is
they wrote written invitation with
quotes
they then later say in the article
they've not actually reviewed the
substance of the invitation or the
letter itself only Communications that
confirm it was provided to Fry's Carrick
and Sullivan strickler employees kais
Carrick and Sullivan strickler are
lawyers lawyers were provided with a
quote written invitation by an election
official to go down and inspect voting
machines
incredible yeah this is the basis of his
his indictment in Georgia that's the the
whole bait not the whole basis but
they're arguing that the D.A has this
and it's a component of the charges that
are being brought against Donald Trump
it's amazing I mean it's hard not to
look at it as just complete desperation
right they want him to be guilty so
badly that they'll just make up nonsense
this is all misleading I mean you're
saying before like has he been charged
or indicted being charged means that the
D.A says that there's enough evidence to
prosecute you so the D.A really believes
there is something on Trump but now we
need the grand juror to say yes we we
believe there's enough to prosecute
right and that just doesn't happen in
fact Georgia doesn't need the grand jury
apparently they say we have enough no
matter what you say and that's kind of
insane especially the grand juries look
how they write this they write this it's
amazing on January 1st 2021 days ahead
of the January 7th voting system breach
Katherine Freese an attorney working
with Giuliani Sidney Powell and other
Trump allies shared a written invitation
they put in quotes again what does that
mean
that someone called it a written
invitation but there's maybe and there's
suggesting that if you want to go and
dig through the story there was an
election official who there's two
election officials One open the door let
them in got in trouble and then one
provided the invitation
to examine voting systems in Coffee
County with a small group of trump
allies that group included members of
Sullivan strickler a firm hired by
Trump's attorneys to examine voting
systems in the small heavily Republican
Georgia County according to text
messages obtained by CNN that same day
fries sent a letter of invitation to
Coffee County Georgia
to former NYPD commissioner Bernie
Carrick who was working with Giuliani
okay so to clarify I don't know that
they say circle is a firm I know that
price is an attorney when it said Fry's
strickler and uh
uh and and uh what's the other name
Carrick who was working with Giuliani
blah blah blah Fry's then notified
operatives who carried out the breach
and others working directly with
Giuliani that show Trump's team had
secured written permission okay well
hold on a minute how come they over and
over again saying this article they did
an invitation and permission
yet they call it an illegal breach
you read like they said they sent an
invitation so was that in quotes like
that element of it like they said look
at this it says price then notified
operatives who cared at the Coffee
County breach and others working
directly with Giuliani that Trump's team
had secured written permission the texts
show
CNN has not reviewed the substance of
the invitation letter itself only
Communications that confirm it was
provided to Fry's Carrick and Sullivan
strickler employees I'm assuming
Sullivan strickler is a law firm I could
be wrong but let me just double check I
don't know what firm means
but uh we'll double it Sullivan
strickler what is it legal Technology
Solutions okay so it is it is not
necessarily the employees are lawyers
one of them was a lawyer just to clarify
because I said they were lawyers in a
law firm that could be wrong all right
either way CNN is clearly lying to you
by burying the core elements of the
story and leading with Trump breached
voting systems and that quote is just
crazy like what like the written
invitation in quotes as though that's
not exactly what they say later in the
thing that they were invited and they
don't have they don't have a letter so
they can't even prove it or are they
implying that the election official who
is probably Republican if he's a heavily
Republican County was rolling out like a
written invitation like he wanted
Trump's people to be there he's giving
them preferential treatments he's he's
part of this conspiracy price I mean
that's what I think CNN is implying with
this yeah I think they're making it
sound like if me and Tim went into a
restaurant and I was like Tim please
take whatever you want off of the the
bar and he's like oh okay and I'm like I
invite you to take anything you want and
then he takes it he'd be the one one
that would get in trouble for stealing
then you maybe would say that I was
conspiring with him so I'd be the Thrice
in that situation I think that's the
angle they're going for but if they
didn't know that it was a crime and they
were invited in by price to go check it
out then they're not on the hook if they
didn't know I mean as far as I know I
don't think so okay but this isn't
exclusive this is so thin like they use
it it's the word exclusive but they
haven't reviewed anything yeah somebody
told us but we can't confirm any of it
yeah we got some texts that said it
happened so we're gonna write a story
that happened and the way they frame it
it's like there's like a trailer out
there of a bunch of wires going in and
the Trump team are hacking into the
voting machine so like it's like if
these if these individuals it's a uh
Hampton and let's see who else was it
Kathy Latham if they were in the wrong
in letting Trump's team into this the
story should be that election officials
were in the wrong and Trump's team
mistakenly entered a presuming that the
invitation was legitimate I mean what
are you supposed to do when you have two
election officials that are like you can
come in here and do your thing you're
like okay who are you supposed to ask
especially if that's your client right
like you're like cool things this is
what we're supposed to be I'm saying
election officials from Georgia told
Trump's lawyers you're good who are the
lawyers supposed to ask if not the
election officials working at this place
I have no idea yeah the Democrats who
are in charge of the state the fake
Republicans who are in charge of the
state who hate Trump or they're supposed
to know if it's legal and Georgia is
saying these officials didn't have the
authority but has Georgia told us who
does have the authority to authorize
this or not authorize it or they're just
saying we can't say but that person was
definitely in the wrong like I don't
understand what what the game plan is
here how are you supposed to move
forward with investigations like this if
no one knows who's in charge except you
can still get in trouble
I think this was bait and the Trump Camp
fell for it they say at the bottom
Latham who also serve as a fake elector
from Georgia after the after the
election has come under scrutiny for her
role in the Coffee County breach after
surveillance video showed she allowed
unauthorized Outsiders to spend hours
examining voting systems there so she's
the one who broke the rules and I think
what they mean by allowed is that she
opened the door and people walked in and
then she wasn't partied whatever was
going on
but I think it's bait the Trump team
they had apparently had access to this
what did they find they find anything
apparently they didn't I think this was
all them dangling the keys over here
while smacking with their other hand
ballot harvesting manipulation through
uh the executive branch of many states
this is what gives Joe Biden the bump
hatred of trump obviously and then you
had the mass bout harvesting operation
you had the ground activists you had
coveted lockdown people were guaranteed
to be locked in their houses you told
them they couldn't leave and then when
Trump's team are shocked to find out
what happened they distract all the
conservative Republicans and sabotage
the Georgia Senate race by screaming
fraud Trump comes out screams fraud
convinces his voters not to vote in the
senate race giving the Democrats the
Senate absolutely remarkable and then
when they go down and investigate it
what do they find nothing
but this makes me remember the J some of
the January 6 uh trespassers I put in
quotes some of the people that were let
in so if a police officer says you're
allowed to come in and they open the
door for you and you walk in and they're
you're trespassing now and they arrest
you reach the capital you might say yeah
I think the cop is the one that
committed the crime in that case uh by
misleading yeah so this right I guess
that would be entrapment yeah do you
think someone would commit a crime that
they would not normally commit like
telling them they're free to come in the
building and then when they do you say
now you're under arrest you're being
criminally charged and whether or not
you say come on in if you open a door I
mean if you're a police I don't know how
that works if you're a police officer at
a locked your door and you open it and
stand aside are you letting them in or
are you just neutralizing yourself and
removing yourself from the situation
like you're taking an action to open
door that is already closed like you are
going from keeping a building secure and
locked to being like I'm gonna open it
and then I don't know we'll see what
happens like of course we were going to
walk in especially if you're standing
there like yeah it's fine that the story
is open
so that's this person here this what was
the name again Freight Freight something
like that they're the one that opened
the door so out of Hampton uh uh Kathy
Latham apparently opened the door oh man
this is amazing it's a terrible day for
Kathy Laughlin I'm sure well I think she
already got fired but
I'll tell you man
you know I talk to people uh about stuff
like this all the time and you get a
mixed bag of responses some people say
this isn't normal and I'm like normal
they're like yeah stuff like this
happens all the time the Civil Rights
era was crazy and I'm like dude
they're arresting their political
opponents
it's happening in real time this has
never happened before and they're
shielding the other one they're like the
like 100 by and stuff oh yeah so crazy
like it's the it's it's the Empire it's
it's a Communist Revolution like Nixon
with Watergate they you know he he
resigned but then they just pardoned him
Gerald Ford pardoned him so it wasn't
like I don't know if that's the plan
here too maybe that's the plan here they
want they want Trump out then they're
going to Pardon them and move on here's
the question Trump they've been working
too hard for this well they don't want
to be president but they don't want a
revolution yeah they wanna that's the
thing like that's they're not going to
go to if they were doing something like
this they're not gonna do go too crazy
with it because then all of a sudden the
people that they want to control are
going to be a lot harder to control so
here's what we're looking at is this a
period of political turmoil which we'll
get through and we'll forget we'll
forget about then it'll be listed as the
Trump era in history and there'll be
some minor conversations about it and
we'll all forget about it I don't think
so is this the beginning of a civil war
a cold Civil War or active Civil War
perhaps is this the beginning of a
revolution perhaps it really just
depends on what ends up happening
politically it could be a politically
tumultuous time which I hope for in that
Donald Trump gets elected he fires
arrests people criminal charges against
these corrupt individuals we say things
like that if Trump gets elected you know
this D.A is probably getting charged
under seditious conspiracy Trump's going
to get a D.A he's going to go in and be
like New York floor like DC Florida
Georgia these places where they were
indicting Trump you are being
investigated for a seditious conspiracy
against the United States for trying to
jail a political rival
the question I have is
what does this become
if in 100 years communist revolution
revolution is what happens
it will not say in the history books
Communist Revolution the news articles
from the day will not read of Communist
Revolution the Wikipedia entries won't
it will simply say that Trump was a
fascist who tried to steal the you know
take over the country and he was stopped
by a group of Heroes they'll make movies
about a ragtag band of dissenters who
work together to stop Trump from
stealing the election and they'll call
it the shadow campaign and then they'll
write in the history of books about how
Trump they'll have a video where Trump
is sitting at a desk and he's like I
want the system's hacked go in now and
then there's going to be some guys
breaking the door and cracking in an
election official going come on and then
they're going to go up and they're gonna
stick a USB into a computer and go and
go whoa that's what the biopics will all
show all the all the all the historical
error pieces or Civil War
in which case it eventually breaks out
into fighting uh dissolution uh
fracturing of government facilities
various factions fight I had a friend
ask me today he said something we we uh
when the news came out about Georgia
indicting Trump I was like this is
insane this is like Civil War era stuff
you're trying I don't even think during
the Civil War that it got as bad there
was threats of of jailing a Supreme
Court Justice I don't think I don't
think Lincoln actually did and now you
have Biden trying to uh jail Trump my
friend's life that's not gonna be a
civil war who's gonna fight a bunch of
trump supporters and then I said how
many people fought in the American
Revolution
you guys know no I didn't as The Story
Goes population it's like three percent
it may actually have been quite a bit
more than that but very very small how
many factions were there in the Syrian
Civil War there were dozen a dozen plus
different factions
like people seem to think that Civil War
means some Trump supporter will come out
file legislation and say we have by
declare we own Civil War bang like
that's how it ever worked the crazy
thing is the conf in the in the actual
Civil War
after the first battle of Bull Run
okay so this is the crazy thing the
Battle of Fort Sumter they say this is
the start of the Civil War
only one guy died and by accident
because they didn't think there was
actually a civil war then you get the
First Battle of Bull Run what was it
Manassas or something they did not even
think there was a Civil War at that time
when we were talking about the second
fight in the Civil War and people were
picnicking and laughing and when the
fighting broke out people panicked and
fled and when the Confederacy won they
still did not believe they were in a
civil war so they refused to March on
Washington wow the Confederacy could
have just taken just one instantly by
marching into Washington after they won
the first time it's like no matter how
much was happening they did not believe
it was a Civil War I read this this I
read this academic article about when
did it become the Civil War because I
was interested with everyone talking
about what's happening in the United
States when will people actually say
we're in a Civil War I have no idea
maybe they won't because something could
change and it could become a revolution
or if it is a revolution they won't even
call it a revolution they'll say hey
they'll say justice or something like
that or Trump gets elected fires
everybody and they just say thwarted a
Communist Revolution who knows and I was
reading about how it at first it was
called the conflict between states and
uh rebellion and things like this and
then eventually after a few years I
think it was like one or two years it
was being referred to as civil war but
it's remarkable to me that they could be
shooting and killing each other and be
like but we're not in a civil war
that's crazy and then you have the story
of John Brown and Bleeding Kansas seven
years of the lead-up of the Civil War
and the people he killed and I'm like
for all we know in a hundred years
they're gonna be like
dude this like the the second Civil War
period was crazy and like we're in a
civil war now and then some dude's gonna
be alive bro we're not a Civil War come
on and then they're gonna go do you know
the story of what happened with Michael
reinel in Portland this communist with
the tattoo in his neck he walks up to a
trump supporter and just shoots him
twice in the chest
just like today we talk about John Brown
walking up to a slave owner pulling out
a gun and Blasting him in the face like
if for all I know could be 10 20 30
years or it could never happen but I'm
just saying like people never know when
they're in the conflict you can't see
the forest you're in it do you think
part of the evolution of the American
Civil War uh was different because we
were used to fighting on our own soil
whereas modern people are used to wars
being things that happen somewhere else
I mean I'm thinking in comparison like
the the time difference between the
American Civil War and or the
Revolutionary War in the Civil War
really wasn't that that great whereas we
were you know we fought in Vietnam we
fought we obviously wars in Afghanistan
but they happen elsewhere so we don't
think conflict happens on our own soil I
mean it does that I mean Civil War was
one of the bloodiest battles ever but in
comparison it's so far back people like
feel disassociated from it no because
they're not even we are clearly at war
with Russia and Ukraine and even now
they're like no we're not
I think it's because people don't see it
they feel like it's happening somewhere
else so it's sort of I think I think you
just can't see the forest through the
trees you're in it so so we're looking
at any reasonable person who has read
the news and understand what's going on
knows the United States is at war with
Russia period we provided weapons and
Intel so that a Ukrainian could blow up
the flagship of the Black Sea Fleet for
Russia's Black Sea Fleet like come on
that's not Ukraine doing it and that you
say you know where I work with Russia no
Ukraine is we're just helping them but I
think it's interesting how you said like
that three percent was in the Civil War
right no a revolution a revolution but I
don't know that that's true that's what
they say well I'll Factor right now it
was so like that it's such a small
number like think about all the normal
Americans that even they don't even know
about politics or even care like I know
people even just two out like an hour
away from DC they could care less and
have no idea what I'm talking about if I
talk about something like this like we
could very much be and I I was trying to
be so bearish on the cold Warth thing
that Tim was saying but honestly the
more I think about it and also I don't
know what they're gonna do the other
thing you're saying earlier about when
Trump becomes president and he starts
ripping through these institutions if he
becomes president like that's something
that's a worst case scenario for these
guys like they they quick Google search
to say a three percent thing is a myth
so let me let me but but keep talking
I'm just reading
okay well they're not damn we're wrong
about that one we'll scrub that point
we're scrubbing that point from the
record but the uh but think about if
you're going to be if you're married
Garland if you're any of the Chris Ray
if you're any of these guys the worst
case scenario for you is if Trump
becomes president if a republican
becomes president maybe you can maybe
cut a deal with like the sand is for
somebody else but like Trump the Trump's
people they've been getting attacked for
four straight years they're coming for
blood like that's the one thing that
makes me worried about when you say that
we this might be the last election we
have in American history at least for a
while or the last real one
the higher estimate is about ten percent
because all there was a lot of militia
involved the Continental Army was about
75 000 at the time when the U.S
population was 2.5 million in that crazy
and so uh a bunch of different sources
say they think the three percent thing
comes from the size of the Continental
Army compared to the size of uh the U.S
population which makes sense but then
when you actually break it down it
doesn't make sense because women don't
fight the elderly don't fight a lot of
younger people so that could
theoretically reduce the total uh
percentage of eligible Fighters but then
you take into consideration active
militia which were not registered or
continental and they say it could be
closer to about 10 percent in which case
a very very small percentage of
individuals oh it's 10 of the available
fighting force ten percent of the
population so like that includes women
and children like little kids too ten
percent of the population it meaning 90
100 of them are men okay so just the
available Fighters 10 of those went to
war 10 of all of the population
fought
of that ten percent they were all
eligible Fighters
it is not that 10 of eligible Fighters
fought well then that means because that
that number will be if if so that's 30
of the population let's break kids so
let's break it in half and say the
population is 2.5 so uh let's say about
1.25 uh million men let's say that uh
400 000 are between elderly and children
uh maybe that's not maybe that's unfair
it probably would be
if uh they're having how many kids are
they having back then let's just say
five yeah at least bro five kids so then
you've got a smaller portion of elderly
we'll cut an ft 2.5 so then if we're
looking at 1.25 it's fair to say yeah
maybe 300 to to let's say 500 000
because there were a lot of children
were on a not eligible you then have 750
000 eligible fighters of that 250 000
fought so we're looking at roughly
one-third of eligible Fighters or ten
percent of the total population what I'm
thinking but I'm just throwing numbers
at the top of my head the point is this
we have 300 some odd million people in
this country right now
it takes only a and only a small amount
of people to disrupt a system in New
York so back in the day think about this
2.5 million people and 75 uh I'm sorry
and 75 000 are continental army three
percent
what how many people serve in the U.S
military service today do you want
someone to look it up real quick
Google search here and then my point is
as Ian is searching this the U.S
population is massive New York City for
instance in the in in the Metro we're
looking at 10 million in the city proper
I think it might be nine but they only
have like 40 000 cops this is a 1.3
million active duty Personnel 1.3
million as of 2022. 1.3 million
so we're talking about what point three
percent of the people of the population
of this country is active duty but it
was 10 times that during the uh the
American revolutionary period
they were during World War II they were
drafting I think three million people a
year something like that so the draft
would you could draft all that matters
is the size of institutional uh violent
forces
versus the percent of population that
are are feeling uh unrest well what I'm
thinking is it's I think when you said
cultural revolution that's what we're
looking at it's a nobody wants to come
to belows we don't want the nukes to
launch China doesn't want to invade they
don't want to trigger some sort of
Hellfire
um but they want to control the minds
they want to get people to turn on each
other and so how many people are aware
of that those are the active fighters of
the Day quotes let me let me pull up
this story for you from the post to
millennial
30 million Americans say violence is
Justified to keep Trump from Power
University of Chicago study the U
Chicago professor said the public is
more radicalized and that's really quite
significant Okay but well before we
opine on this let me read and break this
down because we got to be careful here
they say the study found that 11.6
percent of U.S adults agree that a use
of force is permissible to prevent
Donald Trump from becoming president
this amounts to around 30 million people
but hold on there a total of
3543 U.S adults were pulled for the
survey in June of 2023 with a reported
margin of error of two to three
percentage points University of Chicago
Professor Robert Pepe all right Pape who
led the research said that while he
believes recent indictments against
President Trump have created
radicalization there is also growing
anger and radicalization on the left as
well oh gee you think
the public is more radicalized than it
was in April and it's really quite
significant we've been tracking this
quite a while and this is really a big
bump
what Pape did not mention is that the
amount the number of people who would
approve of violence when it serves a
desired political outcome on the left
dwarfs that at the right in the same
study was determined that the amount of
Americans who say the use of force is
Justified to return Trump to the White
House was shot uh has shot up from 6
million in the past few months to about
18 million it's almost half the amount
of people who justify using Vines to
keep Trump out of office so right now
when it comes to radicalization
I don't know if this actually means 30
million Americans it translates to
perhaps no they the these studies are
done in such a way that they have
successfully in many instances
extrapolated data to a great degree the
only question is margin of error they
say two to three percent maybe it's five
to ten ten to twenty let's say the
margin of error is 10 to 20 you think
that would be fair Ian
um it's tough to tell it's impossible to
tell that's the problem with this
article and it's disgusting that they
wrote that headline that is complete
mislead because they only pulled 3 500
people but do you know how polls work
yeah how do they work you get a small
group of people and then you ask them a
question or a group of questions and
then you can do whatever you want so the
way it works is they have charts
tracking various demographics they pull
the demographics in key areas they
figure out what the majority of these
areas think and feel then they do a
wider sample size of different questions
and say if the cast Castle household 80
per 90 actually 100 of this house
everyone pulled and it said they would
not vote for Joe Biden some might vote
libertarian some might vote Trump but
zero for Biden when they do a larger
poll and they say we called this house
and we were told that they don't think
violence is Justified they extrapolate
that with a margin of error to say
previous polls in the area based on
demographic views and and Studies have
shown that this group tends to vote this
way when we asked them they said this
they then Target a bunch of different
areas and say this 3 500 people is
actually a very large sample size for a
poll I think it's fair to say however
the margin of error could be way larger
and to just immediately say 30 million
Americans say no no we've extrapolated
that data point but it does suggest a
study suggests 30 million Americans
believe violence is Justified it doesn't
mean they will commit the violence
however just that someone else could I
think yeah if they were put on a jury
they would be like oh we sympathize with
what you did either way I think it is
absolutely fair to say this is patently
obvious when you talk to these people
and when you see people go and do men in
the street interviews with them they
they absolutely agree with this in major
cities
in a lot of places definitely I just
think that they should have done it by
percentage like this percentage of
people versus 30 million because that
makes it sound like there's exactly 30
30 million out here that are ready to go
to war right and it also says that the
study says that 30 million people said
it I mean this is completely misleading
distance it could say 10 of pull
response 11.6 percent of Paul
respondents said that violence was
justified there were Millions
inconsequential number like that's a
that's a big percentage uh our good
friends over at the post Malone I have
great friends of post Malone that is
disgusting you guys
30 million Americans did not say this
that's very very different uh but there
was a study that says 11.6 of those who
responded said they would
I don't think the study just went to an
antifa enclave or went to a DNC meeting
and said how do you feel I think they
did a standard uh you know study let me
uh what do we have political crisis it's
from July where do they explain can you
go to the study does it link to it it
just links to a news article
do we have this actually University of
Chicago because if they link to the
actual study sometimes that's
anger and radicalization Rising number
of Americans say political violence is
Justified survey shows a small but
significant share of Americans believe
in the use of force to attain political
goals on the on both the left and the
right it's funny they don't mention that
the study shows that on the right it's
half of what the left wants so this is
from about two two and a half weeks ago
and uh let's see do they have the study
here dangers project has been conducting
dangers to democracy now they just
linked to another one of their own
stories
also if it dangers the Democracy survey
sounds like a pretty biased way of like
there's somewhere in danger you need to
get ready get going well to democracy is
a left biased title because Republicans
conservatives Libertarians don't call
the United States a democracy because
it's not yeah like would you fight if
you were in danger there's a lot bigger
question would you fight you know adding
the danger part of it is like well if
I'm in danger I'm going to be a lot more
likely to fight for myself so here's how
it should actually break down
if this was framed that way and it
skewed liberal in their survey questions
that means that of that 11.6 there's a
massive bias so the number is probably
much less among both groups in fact you
could argue if it's if it if it was left
biased then the political violence to
remove to uh support Trump would be a
lot lower you ask a liberal do you think
violence should be used to put Trump in
office they say no
do you think violence should be used to
stop Trump they say yes if you pull 2
000 Democrats and 1 000 Republicans you
will get the numbers you're looking for
that's the important thing to to track
with these studies but here's what I
want to get to I don't know this is true
all right it may be one in five
Americans believe that the election is
stolen these polls are not always
accurate sometimes they are sometimes
they aren't some of the uh I mean but
but what have they been off by like
seven to ten percent let's just say the
number is seven to ten percent let's
let's track all the polling that we've
seen thus far in the past two elections
from let's take a look at at 2020 and
2022 the presidential and then the
midterms the polling uh oh actually
2016. let's look at from 2016 until now
the polling has been consistently off by
between seven or ten percent
so that means we're looking at 20 20
million people in this country with all
those sentiments if the polling was off
by that much and it could be in the
other direction it could even be higher
it could be 40 million people who
believe in use of force and violence but
when it comes to to plaintively telling
humans how many people want to fight to
kill right now we should be very
specific about who claimed that like it
was only 3 500 people that made those
claims so I do not want to extract 300
360 people of 3 500 people pulled so
it's very very very very very very tiny
and now considering that and considering
the polls have been wrong by about seven
ten percent in favor of trump I think it
stands to reason that the numbers
probably a bit less than 30 million and
we can argue that the 11.6 number is
probably if we if we were to drop it
down it's probably closer to nine
percent and also that's a high high
removal because I was saying just 10 but
that's that's nearly 20 being removed
from that number and people from 11 to 9
but so that then we'd be looking at what
15 20 million people who want to engage
in violence except a lot of people that
answer polls to begin with are people
that are politically activated and those
are the people that would be more likely
to in a situation you know take up arms
I think or people are already aware of
what let's say the amount of people that
want to engage in that are willing to
engage in violence is 5 million
let's say it's uh let's say it's two and
a half million
or three three let's just say one-tenth
of what the actual one-tenth of one
percent three million people I think
when you look at the summer of love it's
clear to see that there are millions of
people prepared to engage in violence
offensive violence I don't know they did
it yeah I mean you know hundreds of
thousands of people all over the country
I mean how many people I know that
during Occupy Wall Street they said
there were three hundred thousand at its
peak had protested in some capacity but
this ranges from actually sleeping in a
park to marching down the street a
couple times when it came to the Summer
of Love riots how many people actively
rioted what do you think 50 to 100 000
because it was all over the country
there had to be hundreds in every city
even small towns
and there were multiple nights I mean it
wasn't just one right and then we call
it a day yeah fifty to a hundred
thousand I don't know what I can tell
you is we had talked about this a long
time ago the amount of people required
to destabilize this country and and kick
off some really crazy stuff it's like a
couple dozen one we already know violent
crime is up in every major city across
the country we know that we are seeing
violence in a more regular basis than we
have in in years past so it wouldn't be
surprising to me that people would then
say like if I feel politically motivated
I would also be willing to act violently
uh that's that's a simple conclusion
draw I don't know what the number on
that would be it just seems like people
feel more unrest and are willing to act
out on that than ever before well what I
think is interesting I feel like there's
a lot of violent people in the country
but to be like purposefully violent is a
like kind of a different thing right
like if you look at like what remember
then Kai sinat had that thing that's his
name right yeah and a bunch of people
space station giveaway yeah and
everybody started going crazy I think
that proves it to be completely honest
that it could happen yeah that that
we're on the cusp of it when people are
willing to be violent and destructive
for no reason you know people talk we
talk about Civil War and they're like
who's really gonna fight uh I don't know
a random guy who's bored because we've
seen that happen over and over and over
again in the past couple years people
just being like it's on I guess they
lose control and they go and smash stuff
you know what let's pull up the story
ladies and gentlemen here we go you may
have seen the video over the weekend we
have this from The Daily Mail Los
Angeles Nike store robbed as shoplifters
hit Topanga Nordstrom again
the latest in a troubling string of
violent Smash and grab incidents
there's a video going around
Nordstrom ransacked for a hundred
thousand dollars of the merchandise
they're not even covering their faces
anymore I saw a video of guys robbing a
supermarket
they didn't even wear a mask just it's
three dudes they walk in they grab it
they fill up their car walk out go to
the car and start filling up while the
guy films them there's a video of a
woman stealing from a store she just
throws it in her car jumps in her car
speeds off
this is what people don't get Civil War
or I should say Revolution or social
breakdown in many countries especially
the ones that I've seen
it is not like a bunch of people go
outside stand in front of a Podium and
say we the people of the Continental
Liberty faction hereby Proclaim it's
like a group of people run through a
building smashing up things and setting
fires for no reason and then in the
chaos people start to seize power power
shifts you get a bunch of people looting
and smashing and then when this spreads
too far and it spreads to political
areas the system breaks down when you've
got these Smash and grabs going on in at
this Nordstrom apparently it happened
again you know I don't know if you guys
have seen the video look at this guy
just filling up his bags being like
ain't nothing you can do about it cops
aren't going to do anything about it
well and if you were to get caught he'd
get released it's California right now
what happens to what does a regular
person think run-of-the-mill law-abiding
citizen says what's the purpose of money
why am I following these rules like why
not not I don't think they say that I
think they're terrified that if they
right now the story is a man rapes a
woman on a train in Philadelphia and the
question is why didn't anyone save her
well because if you tried to you go to
prison like when uh that dude in New
York stopped that guy threatening to
kill people they charge him with a crime
so now people are thinking if you follow
the law you go to jail
if you try to protect yourself you go to
jail and you don't need money to buy
anything because criminals don't go to
jail I think more and more people are
just going to say these are the new
rules that's what's hap that's what
seems like it's happening that's exactly
we're going to live in fear right like
you guys had a different reaction than I
did I would say why would I still live
here why would I go to this Nordstrom if
this is what's happening I don't think
they live in fear before well I was
gonna say before the show I was reading
the story about the 76 year old who got
stabbed when he in the on the New York
subway platform I think this was today
because he refused to give a panhandler
money I mean I think as social order
breaks down people become more conscious
of the fact that like your safety is not
guaranteed which of course you should
always be careful on the other hand
The increased number of stabbings on New
York City public transit is concerning
right did you see the video of the
there's two black guys holding an Asian
guy one one black guy's holding the
Asian guy so he can't move with his arms
locked while the other guy just winds up
and smacks him in the face over and over
again
people just walk by and just videoed it
I don't understand people just watched
and filmed and they didn't do anything
about it it was a stop Asian hate thing
like that was going viral being Asian in
New York actually seems terrifying
honestly I feel like I've seen videos of
Asian guys and old old Asian people
getting just hauled off and just wrecked
by black guys up there it's crazy
I'll say also with this uh La this whole
La a hundred thousand dollar thing I
wouldn't be shocked at all if this is
organized like there's got I think
there's Crim some criminal people out
there right now that see that people
don't get in trouble for stealing the
stuff and they go out there and they
organize large groups of people to go
take go steal this stuff that would be a
mafia mob ever that would be a mafia
then and maybe there is a new Mafia
That's created of just young people that
are stealing and coordinating theft that
would be a new mafia that would require
Federal attention yeah these gangs
exactly yeah we're too busy so I'll
issue I'll show a clarification on this
story
the the viral video that was going
around because I didn't actually I just
Google searched it so apparently the guy
beating the guy being held claims the
Asian man he was beating was groping
women
so great I love the destruction the the
collapse of Society
that's all I mean you know what I even
though like if that's true then we have
this random guy groping women on a
public subway platform and if two guys
get engaging in vigilante justice to try
and stop him from doing it if that's
even true that's not true then it's just
like two guys beating up this other guy
like either one not great for society
does not make me want to take the subway
in New York and this is why people just
don't they tune out they don't want to
look like stuff like this like this is
so complicated like we have no idea what
really happened here like these guys
might have just hold off and attacked
this dude that happens all the time in
New York this guy might have been
growing women if that happens all the
time in New York why am I you know the
farmer from Kansas gonna give you know a
rat's butt about this thing this is a is
a good example of the problem with why
people don't help anyone I just said a
guy a guy rapes a woman on a subway cart
in Philadelphia why does anyone help
because you pull the guy off you stop
him from doing it now you're on camera
beating up some guy and they're gonna
arrest you charge you and everyone's
gonna say they hate you for doing it
just like so so earlier today my friend
is watching the video goes look at this
and I passively see and I go wow I don't
even know what's going on and so I bring
it up here on the show I look it up and
I'm like the claim they made is that he
was trying to sexually assault a woman
so they grabbed him pulled him off and
then smacked him around here's my issue
with it you stop him from doing it then
you stand on a subway cart after you've
stopped it keep his arms locked and then
slap him repeatedly is still not a good
thing yeah
yeah yeah it's I mean I know you say
this whole time it like makes you want
to leave cities like if this is what's
happening you want to be far away from
people which I don't advocate for an
anti-social Society I think Community is
actually important but this is not
Community again you want to give credit
if someone is doing something like
stopping someone else from assaulting a
woman on the other hand do we even know
what happened we can't even trust
anything we hear because we're so used
to a warped media it's kind of
depressing honestly you just don't know
where to turn to wow I mean so so in the
video they've got them pinned they've
got them held back you can see this
they're holding him so he can't move
then one dude knocks him out slaps him
in the head knocking him out then the
other guy starts bashing punching him in
the head several times oh they went way
too far don't care what he was doing
you knocked him out and then you beat
his head on the ground like what the
hell I'll tell you this this is what
happens in societal breakdown you get a
story of a guy raping him on a train and
no one does anything and then you get
guys like this who see a guy going after
women and then they beat the crap out of
him it's like it's like I was saying
with the uh I bring up all the time with
Viva Vendetta when the inspector says
eventually someone will do something
stupid and it shows the finger man the
cops shoot the little girl and then all
of the locals walk up to him with bats
and crowbars and then it's heavily
implied they beat him I don't like
Vengeance and I when I asked I asked on
Twitter I was like okay just ask him for
a friend is Jesus Christ into Vengeance
just asking for eight billion people and
a lot of the Christians you know I want
the Christians to say out loud was
Christ your savior into Vengeance does
he suggest you create Vengeance on your
Foe and people are like no God does but
not Jesus but some people say Jesus is
God so yes it was very confusing but
then there's a question of what's the
difference between Vengeance and Justice
like obviously if someone commits a
horrific crime they there should be
justice but Justice doesn't always imply
punishment so I I don't know I don't
think revenge and seeking out after the
threat has been neutralized to go make
your emotions on that guy like that just
doesn't I don't I do not that is a
repetitive cycle that will grind us into
the dust so we've got to be careful not
to fall into it
I think it's all breaking down
this is what happens during the
breakdown and then eventually people
don't feel safe on the subway trains
eventually things are going to get a bit
worse than this we had the video of the
guys in Stockton beating the guy with a
with a stick now that guy we know for
sure on camera threatened to kill the
store clerks and so they grabbed him and
then started attacking him what do you
do to subdue a guy who he pulled out
some kind of weapon does he have a knife
or something or did I get a knife and
like yeah that kills you one knife to
the chest you die and so they start
hitting him and all they had was a stick
and then the guy just cried then there's
more there's more photos I guess body
camera footage showing the guy in the
ground just being like they stopped
eventually the cops came and got him
they announced they would not be
charging these guys but I wonder I
wonder if this can reverse itself in in
the sense that a culture starts to
emerge where people will
just say we don't care what happens the
cops are going to deal with it and
they'll start attacking the criminals
well we're so just there's so much stuff
going on New York's so big like a place
like this you're so desensitized at the
internet I think all you can really do
is like those guys just be with yourself
protect yourself make sure you're ready
make sure you can protect your family
make sure you can protect those around
you that you care about because we're
getting the point and that's I guess
that that is the destruction of a
community because you only care about
the singular and that in that scenario
but all you can really do out here these
days especially like I live in DC people
are crazy like the rant that guy from
Rand Paul staffer got stabbed I don't
know if you guys have seen that video
yeah that's crazy he was just walking
down the street
yeah and just stabbed him for no reason
there was I can't remember which
congressman was who a guy followed her
into her apartment elevator and like she
threw coffee on him and like he was sort
of attacking her like this stuff is
happening all the time and of course we
hear about it more and more connected
people are connected to someone in the
public space but uh can you imagine just
being one of the runner one-of-the-mill
people who gets attacked on the street
you have to make a report to the cops
and cops are like I know crazy right
people are getting stabbed all the time
yeah we were just watching before the
shows uh footage from the Rodney King
riots in Los Angeles and it was like
Asian store owners just walking outside
and shooting at random Korean Korean
Korean thank you uh shooting at random
people or people that they thought were
threatening their store I don't know if
those people ever got arrested and
charged but we're in the age now of
social media so we've got this
technocratic oversight that's like like
it's it's a temp it seems like it's
trying to criminalize self-defense like
Daniel Penny apparently choked out some
bum that was threatening to kill or hurt
a bunch of people on a train so he
choked him out and then he got he got
arrested for it like he defended those
people and then he's the one that got in
trouble the that wouldn't have happened
in the early 90s that didn't happen in
the 80s when we didn't have social media
where people get to sit and think for
like a week watch the video over and
over should we go after that guy should
we go should we should we they they
mentioned on Wikipedia that no Riders
were fatally shot by any of the Korean
volunteers the interesting thing is they
point out that because South Korea has a
two-year mandatory military service all
these guys had had Firearms experience
so they were warding them off with their
warning shots but they were firing you
know
right like they have experience handling
no they're not someone who just bought a
gun because they're scared and they
don't know how to use it you could argue
that wasn't even I mean that wasn't even
self-defense at that point because
they're defending their store maybe but
I didn't the people weren't near the
store that they were shooting at I
didn't see any people on cameras just
dudes out in front shooting like in diff
around not so much the point the point
is this technocratic March towards
communism is making us look at ourselves
hypercritically and criminalize
self-defense we've got to stop doing
that to ourselves we have to let
self-defense Reign you need to be able
to defend yourself in your community or
the community will fall you have to do
that
I think it's interesting what you said
you we watched that clip hundreds of
times over and over again because if you
think if you've been in like a fight
before or any kind of like physical
altercation it's quick it's not like
you're sitting there and you're deciding
your next move like your Sherlock Holmes
in that movie like you're trying to sit
there and you're surviving you're
reacting and so people like they see the
gauge like oh I wouldn't have choked him
for that long I was like well I'm
holding on that guy for dear life you
know like stuff like that you have no
idea he could get up and kill you yeah
that's the thing about the the guy the
Sikhs in Stockton who are beating the
guy with the stick and there are some
people being like yeah but they they
kept going and he was begging and crying
and it's like and he could kill them he
pulled some kind of weapon and
threatened them to with death and he had
threatened to shoot them in the past
that's that was reported uh in previous
stories and they're not trained it's not
like they're police officers it's not
like they're Jiu Jitsu fighters on the
ground to go wrestle this guy's knife
away like have you seen the video of the
guy who executes I think was a 7-Eleven
clerk yeah he walks behind the counter
he's pointing the gun at him the guy's
on his ground on the ground his knees
just with his hands up the guy opens
right just takes them on your looks at
him shoots him in the head and then
grabs the money just walks out casually
and so we built this system where we're
supposed to tell victims just sit there
and hope you don't die but you might
that's insane didn't some uh maybe it
was a different clerk in like New York
or 7-Eleven Denise stab someone or shoot
somebody that came into the store that
was attacking him yeah that's insane
what was that story a guy a woman a
woman got mad because the potato chips
cost too much money or something like
that told her boyfriend the boyfriend
came in started uh hitting the store
clerk and she pulls out a knife they
fight he grabs the knife from her stabs
the guy who was beating him the guy I
guess he died is that what happened or
no he went to the he didn't die I don't
I don't know if he might they arrested
the store clerk and sent him to Rikers
yeah whoa and then for murder
assault or something and then only after
major outcry did he get released
yeah those guys with the stick could
easily and like if they're in the wrong
place wrong time wrong D.A like we're
talking about the Trump stuff right now
I guess that kind of comes or if no one
caught it on video right like there are
people who are in the right to defend
themselves who don't get the kind of
public outcry that that guy got you're
dependent on someone else advocating for
you it's just crazy it feels so obvious
I don't know if this is true it feels
like foreign governments and foreign
corporations I'm talking about the world
economic Forum talking about the CCP God
knows the Russian government's involved
are trying to get the United States to
fail it's they want us to hurt each
other and to die and and they would love
for us to criminalize our own defensive
capabilities so why would you let that
happen
why think about it
yeah I mean I think you're right I think
people do want to see America fail and
that's why people have to be conscious
of what's going on around them
I I don't know how to help I don't know
how to help besides making some Grand
sacrifice well all you can do is like
work on in your small community where
your friends are like and try to make
sure that they're safe they're healthy
they're working hard they have a good
Avenue to get out of the stuff and I
think about like I used to be a little
bit more like what are we gonna do full
Rebel like that's not gonna that's not
gonna work out like maybe it does maybe
we have to maybe that's what ultimately
it's gonna happen but what you can focus
on when stuff is going on like this is
make sure you're armed make sure you're
healthy make sure you have a good food
supply like make sure you know how to
farm you know how to hunt that's on I
have friends that I've never held a gun
like I've never shot a gun before like
what if it all does go bad and we have
to start hunting and fishing and stuff
like that at least I was raised that way
because I'm from the south like I can't
imagine some of these Yankee guys up in
New York like what are they gonna do
like can't go to the because like can't
go to the Gazebo up there you know or
the true yeah yeah there's nothing like
I mean you you make a lifestyle Choice
when you are choosing to live in certain
cities in certain States and I get that
but I think there's a lack of long-term
thinking you know I think right now
people are thinking well New York City's
beautiful and great and there are lots
of wonderful things about cities in the
country uh cities across the country
it's just the state of them right now
you have to be conscious of the choice
that you're making if you're what you're
choosing to live in yeah we've been
living too fat for too long I think too
I think it's part that's part of it
America's been on top for too long yeah
we're getting soft we don't we never we
don't have to do the conflicts I know
that not that many people have thought
like you were saying earlier in those
battles and like I guess that so people
say maybe not everybody fought back then
but I think that we had some hard
choices that we haven't had to have in a
while and we're now we're facing yeah we
need to prepare for war every one of us
and that's so it doesn't happen we need
to know how to fire a gun we need to
know
it's we're on a kid-friendly show right
and Ian started working out for this
music video and he's getting more and
more conservative that that study was
right I was watching videos about on the
ancient Romans and how they would
conquer capua for instance their
southern neighbors there's a bunch of
farmers they didn't know how to fight
because they lived their whole lives as
just Farmers living off the land and
then when the mountain men came in they
knew how to fight and they were the ones
that took the land so if we don't know
how to fight we're basically these fat
Farmers waiting to be taken and it's not
like that stuff doesn't happen anymore
it's not like these there aren't
hardened Warriors out there that want
our stuff we need we need to be prepared
China wants our stuff
China's got super soldier programs yeah
it's true wait what yeah you didn't know
that oh of course they do yeah let me
let me let me search that one classic
China they just do whatever like
whatever sci-fi thing they saw from the
80s like the China's just gonna try it
look at this story like that China has
done human testing to create
biologically enhanced super soldiers
says top Us official U.S intelligence
agents didn't immediately respond to
requests about whether China seeks to
create soldiers like those in Captain
America but doesn't this make sense
don't they like specifically ask certain
like athletic people to have children to
like create more athletic people like
this makes complete sense that they
would be like if it applies to their
sports but wouldn't apply to their
military what if they made
what if they genetically engineered
humans to be
to like have superpowers let me jump
really high or you know throw lightning
bolts or something would you be really
that opposed to it if they made the
X-Men then we'd all think it's really
cool like they'd be like Harry Potter
and all the Millennials would be very
very into it
possibly yeah yeah or they're just gonna
be like these like Chinese shills like
super Red Army whatever whatever yeah
I'll be X-Men but it'll be very CCP
X-Men you know that's a cool idea for uh
for for a fiction sci-fi kind of thing
though China invents super soldier serum
that gives people some kind of abilities
I would if I were to do it it wouldn't
be super like ridiculous like laser eyes
that's nuts but it would be like
stronger faster jump higher be younger
things like well that was just trt dude
and then what happens is people in the
United States start justifying why the
Chinese Communist party is good
desperately begging for access to their
serum technology
you coined that that's copyrighted for
Tim Caster yeah you heard it here first
they'll be able to see super far like
long distance Vision there will be like
spies working within the U.S that are
just like American citizens who turn
traitor for China because they want
access to this technological advancement
what's our super soldier program like
you you know we got one we better no we
don't I no way you've seen our military
recruiting strategies we're like look at
this girl she's got two moms they can
hold their breath like you need dudes
that can hold their breath for like 60
minutes yeah I was thinking about the
fish man they can there's these things
where they can inject into I'm not sure
what it is exactly some some sort of red
blood cell or uh something this is an
old Tech too like from 15 years ago into
the bloodstream and it lets you like
only breathe once every
30 minutes or something
um I should find this there's those
divers I think that might be some
there's those divers for like yeah 10
whatever they can be like down there for
like 10 minutes or something crazy like
that really low deaths yeah yeah you
mean like just like General deep diving
but that's because of like like you're
it has to do with like the compression
of gases it has to do with like
everything's slowing down for you
there's a whole lot of stuff that goes
into it like because you're going that
like that deep in the water I don't
again I don't know a lot about this but
I've read into in the past in the past
as well so we're getting real
transhumanists in here yeah we are
that's the name of the day dude did you
find it no I I know they're logging this
on mines like in 2012. they've done uh
they do those those Guinness World
Record holding your breath thing yeah
and it's like I don't know six minutes
or something but then they also do
oxygenated holding your breath where you
breathe pure oxygen and like
hyperventilate and then hold your breath
you can hold your breath like 20 or 30
minutes or something ridiculous have you
guys seen the steroid Olympics
they're talking no there's a guy I think
it's an Indian guy who's trying to start
like a steroid a limp like where you can
like use steroids and you like compete
oh my gosh we're watching that over
there number Olympics in 24 minutes
holding his breath underwater what wow
yeah also like how do you occupy your
mind during that time I can't even smoke
a cigarette as well that's what I mean
though like when you are running out of
oxygen you've just trained yourself to
stay totally calm so you don't panic and
use more oxygen well you don't feel like
you're suffering at auction you just
feel how CO2 build up that's what you
get like either one though that'd also
be hard to keep your mind there's
technically oxygen in the water so if
you're and there's oxygen in the air you
can take in through your skin I know
it's a little transhumanist to think
that you can get it any other ways but I
think you can you can drink water and
get oxygen that way so yeah there are
other ways yeah
man I wish I had this this crazy article
that I read 15 years ago about they were
like injecting stuff into people and
they didn't have to breathe the guy
who's got the 25 minute record was
pre-breathing 100 oxygen prior to
holding the holding his breath so it's
kind of like the steroids thing oh
that's crazy so you can just Huff oxygen
and then you can just breathe the world
for longer the world record for
non-oxygen assisted breath hold is 11
minutes and 35 seconds by Stefan for
women it's nine minutes so when is that
gonna be the thing like when they're
selling air because of the air quality
is going to hell because of uh you know
Canada's blowing all the smoke down here
we're gonna start just helping oxygen to
survive is that gonna be the next big uh
like big business they sell those Like
Oxygen cans right intravenous oxygen
injection for patients who cannot
breathe yeah I think this is it this is
from 2012. an injection that delivers
oxygen directly into the bloodstream for
patients who cannot breathe so it's if
someone like goes into cardiac arrest
you can you can get it right into the
blood so you don't need to breathe to
get your oxygen I'm not a transhumanist
guy but that sounds pretty sweet the
fact that like we're basically just
machines that you can just dump like a
little bit of like oxygen into your
bloodstream like this and you don't have
to breathe that's crazy
like wow dude like super steady sequence
of that that's what I think all the time
injection it sounds so fun but like tiny
gas-filled microparticles can be
administered directly into the
bloodstream supplying it with oxygen
they're made of a single layer of fatty
molecules that's around a minuscule
pocket of oxygen that are placed in a
liquid solution and injected into the
patients is that from 2012 also the zolt
attack I wonder what they got now but
it's this crisper stuff I wonder if
people will even need to breathe very
much I I think China has probably
genetically engineered a whole
generation of soldiers that we don't
even just under water stuff to their
kids in hospitals already I assume that
like they already like have like a
cocktail that they're feeding in there I
don't know if they care about the
average person the average person can
live their life fund the economy do
menial labor and then they start
creating genetically engineered super
soldiers for higher level stuff but we
all know how that goes because we've all
seen The Wrath of Khan right yeah
unfortunately ah no I haven't what
happens so the long story short of it in
Star Trek a part of the lore in the past
is that humans started genetically
engineering people and then created
super strong people who eventually felt
like they were better than everyone else
and should be in charge because there's
no smarter faster and stronger and then
I think the story has been a long time
since the movie I think they get Frozen
and launched into space to get rid of
them and then uh the crew of the
Enterprise discovers the vessel and then
unfreezes them that was basically that
might be
um into Into Darkness with the Benedict
Cumberbatch I'm not sure if it was it
was a similar plot for Wrath of Khan but
I think that was I just haven't seen
Wrath of Khan's as a little kid I just
love the future where we when we have a
problem we just freeze it and launch it
into space dude we're like see you later
I can't deal with you anymore people are
still are actually like really doing
that right now too they're like really
looking into some guy dropped out of
high school or something the Free Press
Barry Weiss's paper did an article on it
some guy dropped out of high school to
start freezing people he's like freezing
dogs now but he has other people signed
up that are like gonna be frozen for
long term wasn't that the for like Walt
Disney
when I was gonna happen to Walt Disney
I feel like a lot of stuff could have
happened is it working are they bringing
them freezing into them I don't know if
they're bringing them back I know that I
think they're freezing them now with
like the intention of bringing them back
eventually would you do that if you
could
dude we need something wrong with me you
would come up and your brain would be
half melted like right you think
oh yeah I think it would never work but
the main issue is that freezing causes
water water to crystallize so if you
freeze a person it destroys and ruptures
the cell wall so they need to find ways
to super cool and slow down the chemical
process in the body without causing the
destruction
go through like what spin you really
fast
so that there's constant shake you just
shake you violently because then it the
water can't freeze do you think people
ever ask to just be kept permanently in
a coma they'll be like I'm towards the
other life but I don't like this decade
just keep me in a coma for 10 years and
that will be like a voluntary state if
that seems much more like a real thing
than like the freeze skip a decade
I feel like that's what people will end
up doing if I I don't understand trust I
trust him on this it would be damaging
to freeze and unfreeze The Chronic
chronogenic technology is different
somehow it's they're seeking to bypass
that or whatever so but I feel like
that's what people will opt for in the
interim they'll be like well I'll just
go on pause for a couple years do it
they're gonna be like if you're 13 and
above you're allowed to you can stay
there for about 10 years then you can be
you know 23 instantly like that's crazy
um yeah that would that I mean with a
neural so I'm derailing this
conversation I'm thinking about super
soldiers I just keep thinking about we
need a super soldier program we better
have one because we need to be prepared
there's no way we have a super soldier
program or at least not with the current
federal government I'm sorry I just
don't believe it we have such low
military recruitment rates that's
exactly why we would have the problem we
lower the fitness standard so we can't
even get soldiers into this
because they're no way you know so you
you are you are thinking this is about
them I would like to recruit you to come
here and get injected no they're taking
babies 20 years ago injecting women in
in the womb and then giving birth to das
like docile but aggressive what I mean
by that is I should say submissive and
easily commanded six foot five super
ripped naturally like we do it to cows
right like the US military is willing to
drop nuclear bombs all over the planet
blowing stuff up I would be surprised if
they were not willing to genetically
engineer babies 30 years ago I would
grant you that except for the fact that
our military constantly changes
leadership everywhere so let's think
about like space force right Trump is
like let's bring it back and the Biden
was like no but why the Assumption like
why the assumption that the military is
disclosing to the public everything
they're doing
public but I don't think every Federal
Administration would keep the program
going and there's no way it could grow
faster they lose so much money like
they've like lost like there's so much
money that's not accounted for like
there's I I would not put anything on
the audit yeah like I I don't understand
how so many people think if I haven't
heard it in the news the military
doesn't have it it's not that I don't
think we've had it in the news I don't
think that our federal government takes
our military seriously enough to have
that kind of force that I just don't
trust that bro they do it would be cool
but I don't think if you haven't heard
the military doing it you assume they're
doing nothing this actually is an
argument for the inverse if the military
seems to be doing nothing it's probably
because they're bolstering in some other
way right the military-industrial
complex is not going to just drop their
arms and be like I guess we can't do
anything anymore more and they're not
going to come out and be like we
invented this new kind of bomb if that
is their premium top tier weapon that
makes no sense what makes more sense is
the military National complex wants more
and more money for tons of stuff they've
been doing biological research with gain
of function research and we only just
figured that out banned it they brought
it back so in in my view we know for a
fact China well I should say it's been
reported by using intelligence officials
that China has a super soldier program
I'd be willing to bet the US the US
military has crazy weapons you could not
even think of the idea that imagine if
when we were working on the Manhattan
Project the US government immediately
came out went to the president said we
are currently working on the nuclear
bomb here's how it works and what it
does it will be commissioned in this way
and located in in it'll be located in
these areas that's insane nobody knew
what they were building it was all
speculation and then was it Truman right
he was like let's blow up Japan to prove
to the world the power that we have and
all only then people went holy crap and
the funny thing is when it happened news
took a while to travel these days news
travels fast I'm I'm willing to bet what
makes the most sense is that the US has
been working on insane military Tech
that you don't know about and won't know
about until they need to use it but they
need someone to operate it and they just
can't get anyone in the door to be a
part of the military you are making the
assumption that they are telling you
exactly I'm not and not at all assuming
that I'm just saying that our military
is not in a strong state so maybe we
have a lot of people who know how to
operate these weapons that I don't know
about I'm happy to grant you that
there's no other hand there's no bad
guys working in the government Joe Biden
is so dumb game plan how do you keep the
military alive you can't recruit people
to power but even if I don't know what's
going on
they're not telling you they're actually
recruiting a Marvel movie fantasy dream
I'm happy I'm happy to say there's stuff
I don't know about but I think
ultimately our military is not something
that our government is uh properly
creating to sustain so there might be
one project that has a really great
weapon I'm sure they wouldn't tell us
that's fine but I don't think a super
soldier project is something that they
can actually manage the police hear
rumors that people are drinking
illegally during the during the
prohibition era and they walk past an
apothecary and say certainly there's no
alcohol in there if that's just a
regular old Pharmacy and they walk right
past it because the guy put a sign on
the door saying Pharmacy and we all
believed it and then deep and then you
walk in the door you push the the the
the the the the bookcase and there's
everybody drinking beer the idea that
military is going to tell you their
capabilities I think is absurd now don't
get me wrong the forward-facing military
as we know it is struggling that's in
the news what I'm saying is China has a
super soldier program the idea that the
United States does not engage in
unethical and psychotic behavior is
that's the fantasy because we know that
they were funding gain of function
function research illegally in violation
of the law they did it and we only found
out several years later I'm just so that
means it is a fact they are doing
something behind the scenes we better
have what I'm saying is back to tanks
just getting genetically altered
underground Mountain bases man we better
have millions of dudes which is
gestating right now they did MK Ultra
hundreds of thousands they strapped
people to chairs and injected them with
crazy ass chemicals decades ago why
would they not be like we can make
Superstars so you want to up your
recruit your recruitment dude entice
people with this genetic alteration get
people to go be badass super soldiers
well what I think it's interesting about
like when you talk about Truman like if
they let the bomb go and they knew it
was like there'd be a referendum people
be like we demand a boat I don't know if
you're gonna do this and like that's why
they wait till I'm not going to tell
anybody like they're experimenting on
children like they're gonna be like
there's gonna be a referendum especially
like now these days on Twitter if you
have a bad idea on Twitter we can turn
that around in a day and people be like
that was a terrible idea true so we do
have breaking news right now
Adrian Norman tweeting Fulton County
Georgia grand jury has approved 10
indictments in the Trump investigation
so I think how many were on that uh that
that document that came out yeah let's
clarify this 12. I don't know and so so
it may be those were what they were
proposing to the grand jury and the
grand jury approved 10 of them so this
is the news we have right now I'll try
and see if uh there's any other
developments here what a colossal it
says zero we're nullified by the grand
jury right there so it says zero
no build whatever that means
interesting I hereby certify that on
August 14th after the indictments had
been presented the grand jury and the
session had been adjourned for the day
said indictments were returned in in
open court as required by law president
for said return were assistant district
attorney it says DeAndre I can't read
the last name uh deputy sheriff and
Deputy Clerk of the superior court on
this date there were 10 indictments
presented to the court of those
indictments zero were no billed by the
grand jury this is the 14th day of
August so okay I think I no I think that
people are saying 39 in the chat I don't
know if that's 39. yeah it seems like a
lot I don't know I've never seen
anything 39 personally
well so I I have the we have the
document we pulled it up it's uh it says
one five nine eleven so it just says 39.
okay yeah it said that ten percent of
the church the court zero were no build
I think 13 are listed here it's 13 yeah
okay so I wonder what this document was
but I wonder if they just said do 10.
yeah oops we published the document do
10. I like it matters to him there we go
this is one of them they can find this
is it Trump is being indicted nice once
again in Georgia did they indict item
for that RICO charge I guess it doesn't
say on that no I've done uh I don't
think the news news is just out right
now this is breaking right now
all right so I've got NBC let's pull up
NBC here and see if we've got uh
Fulton County grand jury returns 10
indictments in 2020 election probe for
Georgia it is not yet clear who has been
charged in Fannie Willis's investigation
into efforts by Trump okay so we don't
know if it's Trump but it's Trump
let's see a docket appeared on the
website short of the noon they took it
down Willis enlisted a special grand
jury 75 Witnesses testified blah blah
blah uh so that's it this is the
breaking news there's nothing else right
now we're getting at 9 24 p.m the
indictments are coming in
so
what next what does a sane rational
person in this country do watching all
of this stuff break down and fall apart
uh start to look into the projector for
Solutions I wouldn't flee I'm not going
to flee because I think the the concept
of uniting States as your government is
the best form of government on Earth and
we have states rights so that's awesome
I don't like this current government
that's right being the people that are
running this and the way the way it's
been co-opted the last hundred years but
this organization of statehood is badass
I think that in the private sector we
can find Solutions I just found out
yesterday that they've so they they're
trying to make hydrogen fuel there's
three types of fuel fuel is something
you can put in a bottle it's either
hydrogen carbon or plutonium those are
the only types of fuel on Earth that we
know of we've we've had a hard time
figuring out how to make hydrogen fuel
because it's so expensive to make
creates a lot of carbon dioxide well now
they hit plastic with lasers and they
make hydrogen fuel and they produce all
this graphene is byproduct that they can
sell you actually make money to produce
hydrogen fuel you're making four dollars
and fifty cents for every kilogram of
hydrogen fuel you're producing so we can
become a hydrogen Manufacturing
production facility that's great but
doesn't change the fact that a bunch of
Communists are taking it lowers energy
costs which lowers the pressure on the
people on the civilian area when the
civilian can get together and focus we
can protect ourselves and prevent this
nonsense well I actually think that
would make people more docile and
accepting of the Communist Revolution
oh I think that street violence would
make them more because what if you have
the the dialectic you want a a presser
and a press you want a villain in a in a
hero and then people want to join aside
and that's how the Communists want to
win is by bifurcating so the issue right
now for the US is that you have this
extreme level of violence and political
instability but people are still fat and
so and I mean that figuratively and
literally so they're kind of like look
man I'm not gonna rock the boat because
my paycheck comes in and there's food on
the counter
so if if you're ma if you're if you're
simplifying and producing cleaner and
better energy then you lower the
likelihood of instability and increase
the likelihood that the revolutionaries
take over you think that you think that
stability is makes it more likely for a
revolution I think instability Yeah the
more stable we can make it the less
likely there will be a comment exactly
no no no no no cheaper energy will make
it more no no no the Communist takeover
is happening through the institutions
but it's happening by people saying
black people or and white people they're
trying to get us to fight each other and
and even though we are not poor people
right people basically that's a big one
poor people rich people politicians and
non-politicians things are improving in
this country greatly and have been
improving considerably over the past
several decades so the far left
extremists start getting jobs and
institutions and firing anyone who
disagrees with their ideology
if there's a breakdown in the system in
terms of food shelter water Healthcare
Etc then that stops because it goes to
chaos that could theoretically benefit a
Communist Revolution or it could hinder
it because multiple factions can end up
fighting but right now
you have all of these people who are
gaining control of Institutions I think
just creating a wonder wonder energy or
whatever is going to make people be like
I'm gonna let them do whatever they want
because I get good stuff I don't think
so only because what's happening is this
wealth Gap we've seen the last
consolidation of wealth to the top point
zero zero one percent whatever it's
creating this diet like the people at
the bottom that's the breeding grounds
for A revolution is when you have people
that can't afford food so if we can if
we can make yes there's still going to
be a wealth Gap but the poorest Among Us
will still be very wealthy relative
because they have free energy or super
super cheap electricity how different do
you guys think this would be if the
economy was ripping right now if Biden
was actually ripping in the account like
how do you think people would feel like
with all this stuff going on with Trump
if people were eating well and they're
the same stock stocks that they had with
Trump do you think this everybody would
be like as in on all like no they'd be
saying uh so Trump supporters would be
where they exactly where they are but
you'd have more moderate middle of the
road people saying things like you guys
are crazy it's better than ever you need
to let it go blah blah blah yeah and so
why why don't you why if you're buying
why don't you just keep on with that
he's been in politics for this time you
can't because he doesn't know how
they're completely incompetent and
capable and I I I don't look I honestly
I have no idea they just acknowledge
they're gonna start pulling carbon
dioxide out of the air they've got so
many activists in there it's got It's
it's insane that like when like he's
been in politics for 50 years I guess
he's out of his mind like he's basically
an old man with dementia at this point
but like how do you just completely see
like the economy is the number one thing
in America that people universally helps
everyone like as long as the economy is
high no matter who you are whether it
goes trickles all the way down I mean I
know we have a huge wealth Gap problem
but why don't you focus on that I guess
they're trying to switch our economy
over to green stuff I guess that might
be long-term something they think is
going to be beneficial but Trump had so
many people love Trump because they had
more money in their wallets than they
had previously I think they want the
grid decentralized I think the real
reason for climate change stuff is one
it's a means of control to manipulate
people into implementing policies that
decentralize the US electrical grid
yeah and that's not a bad goal to to
make the electrical grid more resilient
I think that's a noble goal um you know
shutting down small plants isn't the
right move it's expensive and the return
is worse so if you go to the American
people and say we're concerned about war
we're concerned about conflict and
natural disasters so we want to
implement programs that will incentivize
decentralizing the electrical grid
people are going to be like I'm fine
with coal go up buzz off
so they go the end is an i okay now you
have to do it the one thing for me I'm
not even like Coley against Green energy
and I don't like that word I hate
hearing it because I feel like every
person I've ever talked to those
affiliated with some kind of grifter
like the when you see where the money
goes like bring medesta in to be the guy
to be the guy and letting him be control
the money after Obama literally wouldn't
let this guy touch any like energy that
one energy deal of hansberg was back
when he was in office and you're gonna
bring him back he's like Weiss's best
friend or whatever gonna bring back the
given 386 million dollars to Dole out
whenever that was I don't know what
green bill that was that was a while ago
like how are we gonna trust you to be
like to for with our future if you're
just gonna give it to grifters and like
have that money how where was it gonna
go like it's gonna go to that other guy
that foreign guys pocket yeah it's oh
like laundering and stuff we need a we
need a psychological I hate using this
word revolution over and over we need
scientists in in public office in the
White House and in Congress we need more
scientists that understand the technical
Revolution that we're on right now with
free software graphene hydrogen power
Fusion things like that things that you
can I mean Fusion I guess you get to a
point if you can't control the energy
Supply then maybe that that might become
up too I would just take some reasonable
people like we have plenty of scientists
we just need reasonable people in office
that are willing to listen to people
that have a slightly different opinion
than like the you know whatever the
party line is because we just we
literally just need a reasonable people
but the problem is a lot of reasonable
people won't decide to be in politics we
also need to learn how to upscale coal
and get uh oil because the oil industry
is has so much influence over our
government so we need to learn how to oh
oil is pretty cool reuse it when we burn
it and turn coal into graphene to make
it burn cleaner reuse it so it's not
like we're going to stop we shouldn't we
shouldn't go at those guys I we really
need to use the the carbon the carbon's
super super important yeah I agree
um what else would you see want to see
different like I understand the reason
why people argument in politics like yes
it would be nice to have reasonable
people but I think part of politics are
just generally trying to get information
to lots of people so you have to have
someone who can sell it uh that's that's
one of the arguments against any kind of
economic program or any kind of
environmental issue is that no one can
package it that well because the average
attention span is so short and that's
not actually not unreasonable that was
my old job and I was a comms director on
the hill like we couldn't relate to your
voters to the most people's possible you
have to do simple messaging not be not
necessarily I mean speaking ill about
any of it and this is both sides you
have to find what will resonate they're
not just the person that graduated from
high school graduate from college went
ivy league you got to make sure that
every person no matter their education
level has a good idea of what you're
trying to sell like what you're saying
to them what you bring the table versus
someone else and it it silver simplifies
stuff it makes people like that's why
you have like build the walls build the
wall a thing yeah you want to build the
wall but there's a host of policies
surrounding that like to fund the police
is to fund the police a thing yeah where
there's a host of policies that go
around in that but it's way easier to
say to fund the police
the DA's office is going to be holding a
press conference after the indictments
are processed by the clerk's office this
could take between one and three hours
so we'll be long in bed by then but uh
so I guess it come come the morning
we're gonna we're gonna figure out
exactly what's going on it may not be
indictments for Trump apparently they
didn't say these were indictments for
Trump and the Trump indictments listed
13 charges but I don't know what that
means could it mean that they're playing
on indicting co-conspirators Trump's
lawyers Sydney Powell perhaps Rudy
Giuliani or could it be Trump but
but three of the three of the 13 judges
and it's still the the reason these
charges may have been filed is because
they already returned to Trump's
indictments but the grand jury is
actually looking at multiple people if
maybe I don't know if it's possible
maybe it'll come up while we're on the
after show and we'll see it in real time
maybe it'll happen after we're about to
go to super chats I just want to kind of
echo what you're saying that we need a
great works project we need something
that we can all focus on and build
together as a society it was the wall
Trump said let's build a wall everyone's
like yeah I want to build a space
elevator I want to build graphene
tethered space elevator with 60
different elevators up and down so we
can make space drop if we can Galvanize
our culture to focus on a great work on
a great a like a uh a gigantic like like
the Notre Dame Cathedral or like the the
you know that's scary because you think
like that's the climate change thing
like we're saving the world like that's
like you have certain groups of people
that use that same kind of mentality
that one world so that one government
system and that's what people get scared
and now especially on our side we have
people that are always going to be like
scared of stuff like that which is what
the difficulty I find like even just
think about how am I going to message
just to make everybody in America you
know come to a realization that like
we're all the same people like we want
the same things you know there's really
serious problems like that we should
address we start 3D printing houses and
I think that's a big that technology is
available right now they're doing it in
China quite frequently and that would
help solve a lot of problems one of them
including homelessness let's start 3D
printing houses we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and share the show take
that URL post wherever you can it really
does help share with all your friends
we're gonna have a members only on
censorship coming up at uh 10 pm so go
to timcast.com click join us and uh we
would love to hear from you but for now
we're going to read your super chats I'm
not your guy friend says did I make it
LOL also I wouldn't be surprised if they
try to Ecuador Trump they are so
desperate you did make it but only
because our good friend I'm not your
buddy guy is no longer posting because
he says work is picking up so you are
now the first poster congratulations
South Park meme guy well full sentence
says I feel like the internet is showing
that the Revolution Will in fact be
televised in a certain respect I know
it's cliche but I kind of get the whole
this is the last election argument I
don't know if the will to fight will be
there after this well to fight isn't the
thing I don't think I think that's a
misconception this idea again that a
bunch of people meet behind a Podium and
and bang a gavel and say we hereby
declare like this is not reality reality
is nobody has a will to fight until
they're backed into a corner and then
all of a sudden they're fighting and
that's it clearly the people raiding
Nordstrom and Nike stores have a will to
fight so someone's gonna back someone
else to a corner and a fight's gonna
break out
let's read some more Super chats
Mike E says with young men more
conservative I'm afraid it won't be long
before the establishment escalates
things in Europe and ships those young
men off to war that's one way to get rid
of them
yeah draft them all and then uh oh
whoops except for the rich kids they get
deferments because of bone spurs yep
that's what happened in Vietnam it was
disgusting Kenneth Hart says saw your
coffee Ada you guys should total uh you
guys should totally do an ad in the
style of Evil Dead too Sheamus can be
the one in the basement brewed by Dawn
LOL
one of the ideas we had now was because
everyone keeps asking what would have
happened to Ian if he didn't drink the
coffee and we were like maybe someone
runs from Roberto Jr and then either
doesn't get the coffee made in time or
they like fumble the beans and drop them
on the floor and they're like no no and
then when Roberto Jr comes like I'm
making I'm making it but it's too late
and then it just shows them screaming
and backing into a corner and cowering
and then it heavily insinuates you see
like the shadow of the rooster pecking
just and blood splattering all in
silhouette I wonder if if we could start
the next commercial at the end of the
last commercial I'm like waking up from
a dream of the last commercial and it's
like and then the rooster appears again
and I'm like ah but I don't have the
coffee on this one no no no no the next
one needs to be you walk into a room
holding the thing of coffee and your
eyes are glowing you say Hello friends
you should try Casper coffee tastes good
and everyone's like oh thanks Ian this
is really great wow that was really nice
of you then they drink it and all their
eyes yeah and then they're like this is
good that's a good one that's I am
actually drinking this coffee or I did
drink this coffee it's pretty it's
pretty good it's really good
I was like At first I'm gonna be honest
with everybody
the Appalachian nights is so good I've
been chugging it and I was thinking to
myself maybe it's because of where I'm
getting fresh coffee because we make it
fresh we ship them out in small we we
make them in small batches and I was
like it can't be that good can it and uh
I got a couple of yes so then I had some
of the French roast and I was like oh
it's okay I was like wow like the
Appalachian nights is just really good
the French roast is just French roast I
was like you know it's French roast it's
okay it's coffee but man I stand your
grounds Roberto Jr and Appalachian
nights like all of them I just think I'm
like man these are these are amazing
those are Blends though and the French
roast is like a regular French roast so
yeah could be it I don't know enough
about coffee to know the difference
Tuffy's such a wild thing light roast
has a more fruity flavor the beans are
are they're less roasted so you get more
of the beans actual flavor dark roast is
more earthy because it's darker and then
medium is obviously medium is French
does that mean it's actually from France
I don't no no French roast is a style of
a very very dark roast so it kind of
nukes a lot of the coffee flavor so
Appalachian is a very robust dark roast
but it's got a deep like chocolatey
flavor I just I'm gonna stop ranting
about Casper coffee but you guys all
know what to get Tim for Christmas
just buy my coffee Darren Middleton says
hello Tim Cass I've purchased my rise
with Roberto Jr coffee beans I'm in
Australia and I'll tell you what I think
of your beans rip Roberto Jr it was
supposed to be him in the commercial but
his feet were covered with crap and so
Kim tried to wash his feet as she's done
multiple times for many of the chickens
and Roberto Jr croaked literally went
and then he just died suddenly yeah how
old was the rooster he's like two damn
uh and then we just found out that one
of his sisters died oh no
I'll be honest sadness these were the
first fertilized eggs that we got that
we incubated and we assumed them to be a
weak batch yeah and we were still pretty
fresh about how to raise chickens from
eggs like don't take the lid off ever I
don't know right we did all that right
we had three eggs in the incubator with
um with Roberto and his sisters and uh
one of them died
so uh slightly they're chickens man like
this is chicken life yeah slightly on
topic are we shipping to uh Canada I do
believe there is international shipping
okay I don't I'm assuming it's launched
someone said they purchased theirs got
early in Australia that's hot yeah
right let's grab some more Super chats
Alessio De Monte says 2024 is going to
be wild rising cost of living everywhere
bias doj no border control New York City
and Chicago residents want immigrants
out last but not least Biden's sending
out a total of 250 billion to Ukraine to
fight Russia yep oh boy
no comment did you see Biden went down
there what do you think about what's
happening in Maui no comment dude no
comment is a comment it's crazy you
couldn't even manager like this is very
sad like we're praying for whoever like
no comment is his response he didn't
care because he doesn't know what he's
talking about because he's not there
he's tripped over so much stuff they've
told him not to speak and like he's just
completely totally yeah that's what I
thought too Paul taskelo says I'm a
lawyer in 2015 I represented an
iranian-american man indicted for
selling micro Electronics to Iran to
build a nuclear to build a nuclear
missile wow what happened to Trump today
is the most terrifying thing I've seen
in our legal system wow
crazy assumingly to Trump we'll find out
the Pippin Viking says y'all should have
Brandon Herrera on just launched his
campaign for congress in Texas district
23. oh well sounds good we'll get to it
cam girl as soon as has Tim given the
current overt cheating being perpetrated
do you find the claims of 2020 cheating
and ballot fraud to be more or less
plausible not asking if it did but if
current acts make it seem more or less
likely it makes it seem less likely
this is the point
the way they cheat is exactly like what
they're doing now
the governor changed the voting rules
benefiting Democrats the legislature in
Pennsylvania and the courts changed the
rules benefiting Democrats they did not
need ballot fraud and fake ballots and
Chinese ballots or any of that stuff all
they needed to do was put a bunch of
rocks on the scales in favor of
Democrats
what I think they loved was that
immediately Mike Lindell Sydney Powell
Giuliani Trump came out with the most
outlandish and insane conspiracies thus
stopping anyone from figuring out what
they actually did until they published
an article titled the shadow campaign
that saved the election and they
explained what they did with voting in
the park and ballot harvesting and
ballot chasing and then it's like ah now
don't get me wrong
obviously we know about uh there was a
couple hundred to a few thousand
depending on your Source duplicated
ballots in Georgia those were reportedly
removed because they were found out by a
watchdog I think that any any good plan
to manipulate someone needs a red
herring the fact that there was talk of
dominion voting systems and all of this
stuff was the perfect distraction that
through Republicans Trump supporters off
base and had them saying really dumb
things and and and then they were
chasing the wrong things no no I also
want to add this too none of the
lawsuits actually ever got heard yeah
all the lawsuits were thrown on standing
so it's like I don't know if they were
actually chasing a dumb thing or if they
were just making I think they were
making claims without evidence that's
the biggest problem whether or not
they're chasing that there was uh
malfeasance on proprietary voting
machines in secret like okay seek it out
find out let's find out but don't claim
that it is if you don't have the
evidence but the lawsuits were thrown
out and standing they never even heard
the evidence
so there were a whole bunch of suspect
things things that were obvious and
apparent there's a like uh the the the
with Fulton County in the news there
were duplicate bouts there were ballots
that were scanned more than once and
then they got removed because a watchdog
group said halo we found these this made
Trump and many others think hey we
better do a check on these other systems
because if they only checked this one it
could be the case in other places that
is entirely possible but I think the
reality is ballot harvesting ballot
chasing the executives changing the
rules and violation of the state of the
Constitution because the state
legislatures ultimately had final say
and then Mike Pence should have what
should have happened as Mike Pence
should have said lawsuits have not been
heard and so these bouts are being sent
back he should have done that
and he didn't and he called it a
crackpot legal Theory and then oopsie he
went on TV and admitted he had the
authority to send back votes and push
the vote to the House of Representatives
and every all these mainstream results
were talking about it that it would go
to house delegations to vote on who the
president would be considering Mike
Pence said State legislatures have not
certified approved of the the way in
which the vote was held more importantly
there were 48 States involved in a
lawsuit over whether or not what I think
Wisconsin Pennsylvania Georgia and the
other states did was legal and that got
thrown out uh I don't know if that was
standing but it's original it's called
original jurisdiction and it goes to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court said
we will not hear this case so it was
never even heard my point is simply this
impropriety happens in every election to
the degree I suppose is the argument a
lot of people are alike Trump only lost
because of Fraud and I'm like I think
Trump lost because they changed the
rules to benefit themselves exploited
those rule changes and then got a bunch
of people locked in their houses to vote
and that's what did it
I don't think you need to duplicate
ballots to beat Trump so they're like 81
million what's okay let's say a million
were duplicates let's say a million were
fake they still had six six million more
votes why
they locked everyone in their house
told them they couldn't leave killed
elderly people in nursing homes sent
ballot Chasers to the homes of the
people who were locked inside and said
it's Trump's fault sign this and it'll
all go away
I think that really is rather simple
how many elderly people were killed with
the coveted policies when they when they
put coveted patients into nursing homes
for no reason New York was wild New
Yorker lungs Pennsylvania uh California
did it yeah I don't know man I'm not
saying any of that was intentional I'm
saying it had an impact like kind of got
off with that completely like nobody
gave coin with that harder time about in
New York with all those nursing home
deaths I feel like that was something
that he kind of really I mean you know
the sexual assault thing comes into play
and all of a sudden that's the biggest
thing in the news like the sexual
whatever I don't know if you actually
had a sexual assault but he had like a
sexual misconduct yeah they end up
calling it Steve McGee says Ian we need
a weigh-in
uh 139 you went down yeah I was
traveling this last week and I was on
the road for like 20 hours so I didn't
get to eat my 2800 calories I was
putting in like 17 or 1800 but all three
of those days uh and my creatine hasn't
been I've upped my creatine to I think
10 grams a day now but I wasn't doing 10
grams every day I wasn't working out
because I was in the airport
um yeah but I was at 150 but then it
went back down to 144 but and then I'm
down to 50. yeah I was at 150 a couple
weeks ago for one night and then it was
back to 144 the next day so like water
weight big huge dump constant dump and
uh but it stated about 139 for like four
or five days all weekend I expected to
come back and win it like 134 136 but it
was still 139 I think it was 140 before
it came up here earlier after I did a
protein shake how do you feel I feel
really good I do not want to stuff
myself but that's like they're like
stuff yourself stuff yourself like oh I
just don't I just like this like slow
push towards gaining weight but we're
doing a little bit faster than I'm
comfortable with I bought this protein
powder
it's like I've heard it's called gold
standard or something I got no beef but
they got Splenda in it sucralose and so
I buy it
I'm drinking it and I'm like kind of
sweet right there's no sugar in it look
and Sucralose is one of the ingredients
and I'm like right in the garbage yep
and then I looked up I searched protein
powder no sucralose and Jocko I think
it's called milk how do you pronounce
the o with the umlot is it yo I don't
know his last name is that you're saying
Jocko it's called Jocko and that's
called milk it is it's Jaco's protein
powder and it's got monk fruit extract
instead it is the most delicious protein
powder I've ever had yeah dude no
questions asked like that's cool I I'm
I'm I'm Blown Away Jocko's protein oh I
want to try some of that yeah is that
how you pronounce it
I think so
is like oh with an umlaut I think is
that how you say I'm good on the protein
over here so I'll let you guys do that
one yeah yeah it's really good shout out
to Jocko first president oh there's all
sorts of flavors mint chocolate banana
mint gross strawberry chocolate peanut
butter is really good the vanilla is
really good and there's no there's no
sucralose in it there's like very few
ingredients is it whey protein yeah I'm
pretty sure it's whey protein it's got
monk fruit extract and I was very
impressed it's whey protein concentrate
whey protein isolate egg albumin and my
my sealer casein case and probiotics oh
wow that's awesome yeah cocoa very
amazing this looks good did you just see
the uh this like die it came out like
the aspartame thing that we all knew
about Diet Coke they finally admitted to
it like a couple like what was it a
month or two ago links to cancer yeah
they're just terrible for you and like
nobody cares dude everybody drinks
psycho I don't drink that stuff the
story of stuff and Donald Rumsfeld and
Diet Coke and aspartame becoming legal
is horrendous you gotta look into it yep
all right Matthew wilf with him says you
fools keep saying Trump 24 when he lost
last time he's older and much more
damaged now what's the difference who
are you voting for
he's hitting every he's he's getting out
of the park every time yeah right it's
just he's nailing it you know I don't
agree with everybody I don't agree with
of vivekan I'm sorry I didn't interrupt
what are you gonna say I was gonna say I
thought his ceiling was Fox Business
host but I feel like now he's really
picked up like I thought this was all
gonna be you know like a big because
with these guys they come into the
elections they're not actually serious
and all of a sudden people really really
like this guy like he like he's what
he's above pulling above the sandus now
like he's like a real like I'm not gonna
say a contender Trump so like what 50 45
or whatever it is high but like Vivek is
gonna be there to stay what I think is
like I don't like everything about
everybody there's no one that I like
everything about what they say I don't
agree with everything someone says
nobody and I don't agree with everything
Vivek says and I go hard to the paint
with that guy about debates if if I got
it but he's the guy he's the brilliant
young man that I want in the office
right now I don't know I I like Vivek a
lot there's some stuff that I just like
don't agree with mom like or a lot of it
comes down to immigration and I think
there should be more restriction on
legal immigration as well as illegal but
I'm glad that he is in the conversation
I think he's doing a lot for the
Republican party just by breathing new
life into it I would you know there was
so much infighting with just the
DeSantis Trump team there still is
obviously that at certain point you just
are halting any sort of progress forward
so he's doing all of us a favor even if
he's not exactly who I would pick it's
nice to have billionaires or
multi-millionaires doing it so they
don't have to raise money like to hold
the Santa's pandering for money thing
was really pathetic I like guys that
just self-made
and he was supposed to be the guy that
was getting all the donors too I like
you like Trump that people are supposed
to be afraid of trump and so the sanus
was going to get all the big money
donors but
it still looks like it's not taking like
you're still third like
vivec you're not a Santa's person
I mean I I thought he was the future and
I just thought he's just not the person
that like Trump's the ultimate
personality and it's I think part of it
and people don't understand like Trump
was on TV for so long so many Americans
know him so well and you can't just be
DeSantis and come in and not be personal
I I can I can summarize it very simply
um
Ron DeSantis his campaign explicitly
told their people not to come on this
show
Vivek Rama Swami has been on
Tim cast iron twice dude he came on when
you weren't even here once when I was
not even here it was on shimcast he's on
shimcast and he came on the culture War
for a one-on-one conversation that was
really really great he doesn't shy away
from conversations he'll allow people to
ask him challenging uh questions and
he'll answer them very quickly Rhonda
sent us his campaign cowards in fear and
just flame Wars on Twitter it's just wow
it's crazy like him he's doing a great
job in Florida but campaign-wise they're
just like walking out into a field and
farting
did you feel like his change in Staffing
was going to help at all you see he got
it he has a new Chief of Staff or
something right I know I said great it's
good that he did it but nah it's I don't
I don't know if that dude can recover at
this point it's remarkable his campaign
manager was this woman they fired her
but they didn't fire from the campaign I
think they just fired her from being the
campaign manager right so how do you
keep that person on
like with the and everything's tanking
like that just I don't know that well
there is one of one of the controversies
that was in the news was that he fired
Will Chamberlain Will's a friend a
friend of the show and one of my friends
and uh they fired him and then his and
then his governor's office hired them
and so that was a huge Scandal because
uh I don't think anyone really cares
that much but they were like a lot of
people immediately pointed out Trump
supporters pointed it out
you basically have someone who's living
in DC now working for the Florida
governor
through their Florida governor's office
but they live and work in DC so what the
argument was he was using Florida
taxpayer dollars to pay the salary of a
Communications expert in DC for his
political campaign
that's a bad book well that's a bad look
you know I'm not gonna I can't I don't
want to be biased because I'm friends
with will but that's what the media
reported I don't know what else to say
about it
let's grab uh we'll grab some more Super
chats here
Rudy cassone says if my memory is right
only about a third of American of the
American population supported the
revolution I believe it's actually more
than that there was a letter written
where I can't remember who said this
they said a third supports it a third of
poses and a third doesn't care but that
wasn't a legitimate poll it was just
like an opinion statement I think it was
actually closer to half but not over
half I think I I think
it was all and like opposition was only
like uh 20 support was like 39 to 40
percent and then don't care was the
remainder
I think don't care was bigger than
opposition
hmm
let's see I wonder if they pulled like
500 people and then they extrapolated it
to five million sorry Dabo de zafa says
Oliver Anthony's Richmond north of
Richmond is not a song but rather an
Anthem it's a great song I dig it and uh
he lives super close he's not that far
away a couple hours but I love how the
left is responding to this saying that
he's an industry plant that he's
complaining about welfare after this
yeah and it's just like I remember I
remember when the the left used to sing
about the oppress oppression of the
working class right but now they're
they're just cheering on Neil Young
Amazon and Walmart yeah creeps
Clearwater dude that's like yeah bring
it back yes yeah remember when the song
was uh some uh some folks are born made
to wave the flag and and it's like a
song talking about how when the draft
comes you've got these wealthy
individuals who can dodge it you know
I'm not a senator's son now these are
the people cheering for war in Ukraine
yeah it's wild crazy crazy tournaments
you know what I mean I can't wait for
that New York Times hit piece on that
guy like this random dude that just made
one popular song in the middle of
nowhere and they're gonna send a liberal
reporter to go try to ruin his life dude
he's like he's a factory worker and
we're calling about industry plan I'm
like that's no that's not how that word
works that's not what that means I think
they're just jealous of his glorious
beard it's got like the most intense
Ginger beard I've ever seen that's so
incredibly orange yeah yeah Triton 54
says raising my glass to Jeremy Hamlet
tonight he unexpectedly lost his father
this morning I'm sure he'd appreciate a
kind word sorry to hear it Jeremy uh I
hope you I hope everything uh Beyond
this is okay I hope you're doing all
right and I hope it it you know I hope
uh I hope for the best yeah let me know
if you need anything man I love you man
where are we at norin blither says hey
Tim cast iron can you put in a word to
YouTube to cough up the 100K plaque to
my favorite female YouTuber at the
Crimson cure it would mean a lot thanks
I can say that there's not much else I
can do not like YouTube's got a hotline
I can call uh but uh there you go maybe
someone at YouTube heard me read that I
do know that there's people at YouTube
who do watch the show every night how
often do you guys how frequently do you
get the flap once you hit the number
what's the delay on getting it because
you've done it multiple times you're the
only expert in the room or maybe you've
gotten one I don't know so here's here's
how it works because I'm uh
you know I'll just I'll just say I'm a
little crafty the first time uh I had
100K nothing happened and I was like so
what's supposed to happen how do I get
the silver medal or whatever silver
reward
several months later like six or seven
months later a drop down bar appeared
and it said congratulations on reaching
100 000 Subs click here to get your
award which brings you to a portal for a
website they send they gave you a code
you put in that code and it allows you
to claim your plaque you it says what's
your channel what's your code and then
you submit
the next time I hit 100K I did not get
the drop down several months went by so
what I did was I went and found the URL
from the last time I had logged in used
the old code and then when it asked me
for my channel name put in my other
channel name and it worked interesting
and I'm telling you too that's what I
did because I guess the company then
checked the YouTube channel connected it
and said it does have a hundred thousand
Subs it does qualify and then I did that
again for all the rest but um you have
like one Lincoln code because we
actually got two uh gold plaques for one
of the channels dude I want some brand
know to ride with you guys at YouTube we
got to do like a YouTube Tim cast event
we used to do YouTube stuff all the time
man YouTube events YouTube live yeah
they had they had to uh they had I think
libertarian Party candidate on with Phil
DeFranco in uh 2012 or something like
that because they were like we want to
challenge the system and no no because
like rumble's all about branding their
people and I'm not saying we're gonna
wear YouTube hats but it'd be cool to do
a YouTube event yeah
Steven says says Ian in both Hebrew and
Greek the word for justice includes
Mercy only in Latin did Justice equal
Vengeance interesting
that is very interesting Jason
Hutchinson says we're in an age of
reality denial Up Is Down Down is up
people get money for nothing stolen from
people that create like the gods of the
copy book heading headings the longer we
deny reality the greater the terror and
Slaughter when reality returns hmm
yeah let's grab a couple more
wolves bang 93 says shout out for
Brandon Herrera running it for district
23 in Texas shout out
Gabriel Lopez says nukes are fake the
Japan ones were just tons of TNT the
cities there right now are radiation
free and built better than American
cities a Democrat Governor does more
damage than that aha but I don't think
the nukes are fake
because um we've won many of them
there's videos and I don't think TNT can
do all of that but uh you need to
understand radiation is a choice
I was reading about nukes I did a I did
a video for Discovery you can watch it
it's called um like I forgot what it's
called how powerful are nuclear weapons
or something got like a million views
overnight it was it was a big video we
did a bunch of research on it and um I
learned that the reason there's
radiation in a nuclear explosion is
because they want there to be for
long-standing damage long-lasting damage
so it's possible to have nukes without
it aren't there nukes now that don't
have it or something like that there's
always been oh really yeah always been
uh there's like nukes nuclear bombs that
have almost no radiation and a massive
incendiary wave like they've built crazy
stuff
just like the super soldiers in the
basement perhaps uh yeah someone someone
did point out I missed the super chat
but they did point out that the US
literally did have a super soldier
program they tried to create psychic
soldiers oh like they don't still no
that's the point they had the menosteric
goats I hope they do and they also uh
they were trying to create psychic
soldiers oh I'm so into that you guys I
can come like I can train your psychics
they did MK Ultra the menosteric goats
it's like come on you know that there's
another program where they're trying to
do something else they're not telling us
I was gonna say earlier like there's
there's a reason they failed the audit
you know there's a reason yeah yeah
that's that's that's one of the craziest
that video who was that with was that
bill Mayer that was talking to Bill
Maher he's talked about it numerous
times yeah that was one of the like
she's like I don't know where it is like
he's like yeah you're the accountant of
the like yeah they know El comodi says
speaking of aspartame I'm seeing YouTube
ads promoting Aspartame is safe oh that
is laughable wow no way I'm not a doctor
though I don't know I just don't drink
the garbage all right everybody I I try
to I I try to stay away from things that
aren't food so that's why when I found
out there was sucralose in my which is
basically Splenda was it my protein
powder I was like I will I'm not going
to drink this and then when I looked up
uh Jocko's milk I guess yeah anyone yeah
I don't know how to pronounce it oh with
it yeah when I looked that up and uh the
ingredients are very simple I was like
that's legit but I think you Ian you're
actually just drinking straight away
yeah a naked way nothing else literally
just that's my main one then I have this
this uh bulk fattening one where they
really want me to has tons of crap in it
but the other one is just pure naked way
I love that Ian's agreed to eat a pint
of Ben and Jerry's every night before
fake news fake news no no I did not
along with you when you were saying to
do it yeah
Ben and Jerry's every night before just
before the show she'll be a better fat
like maybe I'll just eat sour cream I'll
just eat loads of it like for a couple
days that sounds so much worse that yeah
that's probably way better to be
completely honest yeah why not uh what's
it what's a good avocado and sour cream
yeah that sounds awesome awesome like uh
paprika on it and some salt that sounds
hot and just eat a thing of sour cream
with some shrimp I don't like sour cream
though so this just sounds lower
horrible I I I I I probably eat like a
cup of a couple of sour cream with every
fajita dinner I do yeah but I also do
like a 1 4 cup of heavy whipping cream
for breakfast that's all I have I don't
have a full breakfast I just have heavy
cream in my coffee and then I eat dinner
that's it you know I ate a couple pieces
of Cheesecake when we went out to dinner
a couple weeks ago and then that did
increase my appetite putting that sugar
in my stomach sugar will do it yeah what
um uh I think it was Andrew WK I could
be wrong party hard yeah he said if you
want to if you want to gain weight
because a lot of people struggle with it
you uh eat something salty and then
after a little while you'll crave
something sweet eat something sweet then
after a little while crave something
salty and you go back and forth and
you'll you'll bulk up real quick but not
necessarily in the good way all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends but more
importantly become a member at
timcast.com by clicking join us to
support our work directly if you like
the work that we're doing we really
could use your support and you will get
access to the uncensored show which is
coming up in just a few minutes you
don't want to miss it uncensored and you
can even submit questions and call in
and talk to us and our guests you can
follow the show at timcastir everywhere
follow us on Instagram WE Post Clips you
can follow me personally at timcast
follow me on Twitter right now I pinned
the cast boot commercial at the top of
my page which will soon be running
everywhere you and we need you guys to
tell us Discord what TV channels we
should run this commercial on and uh
again smash the like button uh JW
Gibbons you want to shout anything out
uh yeah please like And subscribe Man
versus Street on YouTube we do a bunch
of different content we ask people about
a variety of different things um we
asked you know people if they would date
transgenders we've asked people uh if
they want to have kids young girls they
don't have kids we've asked we'll ask a
variety of questions we'll keep asking
them until we get the right answers
which might not be for a very long time
so we're gonna need your support
um thank you one last thing we do ship
Casper internationally now you can go to
casper.com it will go International
that's cool that's awesome I'm Hannah
clear brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should follow at timcast
news on Twitter and Instagram you can
see work from me and all of our other
journalists including Chris Bertman and
Adrian Norman who are great uh you if
you want to follow me personally you can
find me on Instagram
thank you so much I'm Ian Crossland you
guys have a great night Joel's good to
see you man good to meet you good to
meet you too good talking and uh people
are gonna follow you on Twitter or on X
rather at Joel W Gibbons V that's me I
also I want to answer Tom L you asked if
I was wearing shoulder pads you are
correct sir there are they are built
into this this corduroy jacket and for
final uh you've heard of pfas pfas per
polyflorological substances they call
them forever chemicals about six months
ago five months ago there was a scare
and they're like we're all gonna die P
fast it's everywhere we can't they're
there forever well they figure out how
to remediate them out of the soil by
pulsing soil with lasers flashing it
into graphene you can actually withdraw
the toxins reintroduce the graphene back
into the ground and it functions as the
California soil California says it's
good soil when you do that so we're good
catch you later
sweet that's cool
um my name is serge.com on the internet
uh are you on Twitter it'd be great I
will see you guys in the after show
let's do this we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out